selamün aleyküm arkadaşlar 10 şubat 2025 pazartesi günü saat 19.31 62. ders günümüz dersimize
başlıyoruz kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin
lütfen değerli arkadaşlar şimdi concurrency konusu çok geniş arkadaşlar yani 100 saat konuşsak 100 saat daha konuşacak konu kalır genel olarak ama biz belirli bir ayrıntı düzeyinde bayağı da aslında ayrıntılı gidiyoruz bir de bildiğimiz kalan derslerde ilerleyebildiğimiz kadar ilerleyeceğiz.
Şimdi geçen derste this thread namespace'i oradaki fonksiyonları gördük thread sınıfının bütün fonksiyonlarını gördük thread nasıl oluşturuluyor onları konuştuk thread'e codable'lar nasıl geçiliyor bütün bu konuları gördük ondan sonra all once ve once black böylerini gördük
bir kodun birden fazla thread tarafından bir kez çalıştırılmasını sağlıyordu bir de neyi gördük şöyle hatırlayalım arkadaşlar ayrı bir modern c++'da direklenen ayrı bir storage class
kategorisi
kategorisi modern c++'dan önce yoktu neydi bu yeni hayatımıza giren storage klas kategorisi arkadaşlar thread local yani artık dört tane storage klas var c++ modern c++'la birlikte
ve otomatik statik dynamic dinamik Türkçesiyle ve thread local arkadaşlar şimdi bugünden sonra birkaç ders artık ne kadar zamanımızı alırsa
senkronizasyon konusuyla ilgileneceğiz.
İngilizce burada kullanılan term synchronization burada kast edilen arkadaşlar birden fazla thread'in aylaşımlı olarak verileri güvenli bir şekilde kullanması çünkü geçen dersimizde şöyle bir şey söylemiştik arkadaşlar
arkadaşlar geçen dersler geçen derslerden birinde burada en tehlikeli durum İngilizce arkadaşlar data race dediğimiz durum doğrudan tanımsız davranış neydi data race hatta şu iki terim birbiriyle karıştırılmamalı demiştik bir race condition ikincisi data race
race condition aslında birden fazla thread'in biri yazma amaçlı olabilir diğerleri okuma amaçlı olabilir aynı veri üstünde işlem yapması fakat race condition dediğimiz zaman bir tanımsız davranış olmak zorunda değil demiştik peki ne dedik
olsa olsa olsa programınızın lojik yapısında bir problem olabilir mesela diyelim ki bir değişkeninize dört thread birden erişiyor ama sizin mantığınız thread'lerden birinin onu önce erişmesi ona önce erişmesi onu değiştirmesi ondan sonra diğer thread'lerin yeni değerini okuması
siz şimdi bir senkronizasyon mekanizması oluştursanız dahi örneğin bu sırayı sağlamazsanız programın lojik yapısı yanlış olabilir yani buradan İngilizce tabiriyle race condition arkadaşlar tanımsız davranış olmak zorunda değil İngilizcesiyle benign olabilir yani iyi huylu olabilir ama data race dediğimiz zaman
her zaman kötü bir durumdan bahsediyoruz data race programın ölümü zaten cppreference.com'a bakarsanız arkadaşlar birçok yerde data race olup olmayacağı açıkça belirtilmiş bazı öğeler için
dolayısıyla bizim data race'den kaçınmamız gerekiyor o zaman data race'in tam birebir Türkçe'ye çeviriyorlar data veri race burada yarış anlamında veri yarışı yani adeta o veriyi kapışmak paylaşmak için birden fazla thread yarışıyor gibi
arkadaşlar yalnız data race de bir şeye dikkat etmemiz gerekiyor mesela 10 tane thread olsa 10 tane thread de aynı değişkeni okuma amaçlı kullansa o zaman bir problem olur mu bir problem olmaz
arkadaşlar işte bu da bazı programlama dillerinde bütün veriler immutable onlara girmek istemiyorum şimdi immutable data ile uğraştığınız sürece
multi thread programlama tarafında bu senkronizasyon sorunu yok çünkü sadece değişkenleri örneğin okuma amaçlı kullanıyorsunuz ama en az yazma amaçlı bir thread
o veri üstünde çalışıyorsa o veriyi kullanıyorsa diğerleri yazma amaçlı da olsa okuma amaçlı da olsa bir senkronizasyon olmadığı sürece arkadaşlar
ne olacak bu data race oluşacak şimdi data race ile birlikte bir başka problem daha var senkronizasyon konusunda meşhur hangi terim deadlock
arkadaşlar biliyorsunuz buradaki dead ölü demek lock da kilit demek yani birebir türkçeye çevirirsek ölü kilit
burada birazdan göreceğiz arkadaşlar data race'i engellemek için tipik olarak biz mutual exclusion kullanıyoruz
evet karşılıklı dışlama diye türkçeye çeviriyorlar şimdi türkçe terimlere pek de alışmadığımız için ben türkçeyi savunuyorum keşke bütün terimler türkçe olsa
ama şimdi herkesin kulağı ingilizce terimlere alışmış oluyor türkçesi biraz tuhaf kaçabiliyor ama bence daha büyük problem
tuhaf kaçsa da alışırız daha büyük problem şu farklı kişilerin farklı kaynakların aynı ingilizce terim için farklı türkçe terimler kullanması
yani örneğin ingilizce de olan diyelim deadlock terimi için birden fazla farklı terim öneriliyor
o zaman gerçekten bir terim karmaşası oluşuyor
evet o zaman bu konunun yine ilerleyen saatlerde ele almamız gereken önemli alt başlıklarından biri
arkadaşlar mutual exclusion bu çok geniş bir konu ve buna bağlı olarak deadlock dediğimiz durum programların yine ölümcül ne diyelim düşmanı deadlock
arkadaşlar şimdi önce geçen dersimizde biraz konuşmuştuk hatırlatalım
mutual exclusion ne demek
mutual exclusion'ı anlamak için önce bir tanım daha yapmamız gerekiyor
nedir bu tanım critical section
burada ben doğrudan ingilizce terminolojiyi kullanacağım
critical section
arkadaşlar herhalde bunu türkçeye çevirmeye gerek yok
kritik bölge
kritik bölge de şu demek
öyle bir kod alanı ki
tabi bu kod alanı dediğime göre bir fonksiyonun içinde olması gerekiyor
kod alanı içinde
bu bir blok olabilir
bir fonksiyonun tamamı olabilir
bir if deyiminin doğru kısmı
ya da bir
for while do while gibi döngü deyiminin gövdesini oluşturan bir blok olabilir
fakat o kod içinde
işte bir değişken
paylaşımlı olarak kullanılıyor
ve o değişken yine birden fazla thread tarafından kullanıldığında
en az bir tanesi yazma amaçla ona erişiyorsa
burada data rayisi veri yarışını engellemek için ne yapmak durumundayız?
bunu engellemek durumundayız
bunu engellemeye yönelik tek bir araç yok
ama araçlardan biri ne?
mutual exclusion kullanmak
mutual exclusion kullanmak için arkadaşlar
mutex denilen sınıflar türünden nesneler kullanıyoruz
burada mutex'in uydurma bir sözcük olduğu açık
mutual'ın mutu exclusion'ın eksi
standart kütüphanemiz birazdan göreceğiz
bize bir takım mutex sınıfları veriyor
yani mutex tek bir sınıf değil
birden fazla mutex sınıfı var
nedenini konuşacağız
ama yeni olarak yapı şöyle
bakın aslında son derece basit
threadlerin bir şekilde ortaklaşa kullanabileceği
bir mutex nesnesi olması gerekiyor
buraya dikkat
yani bir
şuraya da yazalım
diyelim ki bizim burası critical section
alttaki bloğu kastediyorum
critical section ne demek?
burada data race riski var
o yüzden şunu sağlamamız gerekiyor
buraya dikkat
bir thread buraya girdiği anda
diğer threadler blokü olacak
yani iki thread birden
bu critical section'a girmeyecek
peki bu nasıl sağlanıyor?
adeta geçen verdiğim örneği hatırlayın
lavaboya birden fazla kişi girmeye aday
ama orada bir anahtar var
ilk giren anahtarla orayı kilitliyor
artık orada lavaboyu bekleyenler
beklemek zorunda içeri giremezler kilitli
içeri giremezler
zaten naoş durum ya da durumlar oluşur değil mi?
lavabodaki
kişi
içini bitirdiği zaman
kilidi açıyor
çıkıyor
hemen oradan kilidi
anahtarı
başka birisi kapıyor
bu sefer o giriyor
o kilitliyor
yani o lavabo
kilitli olduğu sürece
sadece
o kilidi alıp kilitleyen
anahtarında kendinde olduğunu düşünelim
sadece o kullanabilir
ikinci bir kişinin oraya girme şansı yok
işte critical section'ın
mutexlerle korunması da böyle
bir mutex nesnesi
basit olarak
yani en basitinden
çünkü birden fazla mutex sınıfı var demiştim
bunların birazdan göreceğiz
en basiti
doğrudan
standart kütüphanenin
mutex isimli sınıfı
bir mutex nesnesinin
basit
en az iki tane fonksiyonu var
fonksiyonlardan birinin ismi
lock
biliyorsunuz İngilizce'de
lock hem isim noun
hem de fiil
kilitlemek anlamında
bazen böyle hızlı konuşurken
kilitlemek kilitlemek
kitlemek
şeyi geçiyor
ama kilitlemek diye bir şey
Türkçe'de yok
yani varsa da kit haline getirmek
olur
ama ağızdan
kilitlemek diye çıkıyor
artık onu da
al kabul etmek gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
ne yapıyor
burada
buraya giren
threadlerden biri
girmeye aday
mutex'i
mutex nesnesinin
lock fonksiyonunu çağırıyor
şimdi
lock fonksiyonunu çağırdığı zaman
buraya
on tane threadle girse
lock fonksiyonuyla
bu threadlerden
sadece biri
kilidi edinebilir
threadlerden biri
kilidi edindiği zaman
buradaki terime
bakın
kilidi edindiği zaman
ister
burada kilide edinmek
terimini kullanayım
ister
kilitlemek
mutex'i kilitlemek
terimini kullanayım
aynı şey
mutex'i
ilk gelen buraya
artık o
deterministlik değil
thread
kilitleyecek
artık kilitlediği zaman
bakın bakın bakın
buraya gelen
diğer threadler
burada ilerleyemeyecek
bloke olacak
threadin bloke olması
demek
o threadin
kodunun
çalışmaması
demek
aslında bu işletim
sisteminin bir
faaliyeti
böylece
mecbur
diğer
threadler
bu
mutex'in
unlock fonksiyonu
çağırılana kadar
orada
bekleyecek
ne zaman ki
bu kilidi
eline geçen
thread
mutex'in
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
unlock fonksiyonu
çağırıldığı zaman
artık kilidi
açmış olacak
kilidi
bunların hepsini
aynı anlamda
kullanıyorum
ingilizce'de
unlock
gibi bir terim
kullanıyor
çoğunlukla
kilidi
açmış olacak
ve böylece
orada bekleyen
ya da bekleyenlerden biri
bu kilidi
eline geçirecek
eline geçirilmesi
demek bu sefer
o kilitleyecek
yerleri yine
beklemeye devam
edecek
burada bir şeye
dikkat edelim
yalnız
diyelim ki
buraya 5 tane
thread aynı zamanda
girdi
bunların isminin
thread
A, B, C, D, E
olduğunu düşünelim
diyelim ki
thread
C
kaptı bunu
bu arada bakın
hangisinin
kilidi ilk olarak
alıp
kilitleyeceği
deterministik
değil demişti
o bıraktığı zaman
orada bekleyenlerden
hangisinin
kilidi
alması gerektiğini
seçebiliyor muyuz
doğrudan
hayır
orada bekleyenlerden
biri
alacak
böylece
bu
critical section
içinde
sadece ve
sadece
bir thread
aynı zamanda
buradaki
işlemleri
gerçekleştirecek
buradaki işlemleri
niye
böyle
kilit altında
çalıştırmak
istiyoruz
çünkü
burada
arkadaşlar
shared
ingilizcesiyle
data var
bakınız bu
shared data
yani paylaşman
veri
global bir
değişken
olabilir
arkadaşlar
efendim
sınıfın
statik elemanı
olabilir
bu fonksiyona
referans
semantiğiyle
ya da
pointer
semantiğiyle
geçilen
bir nesne
olabilir
ama tabii
geçen dersimizden
hatırlayın
neleri
bir
senkronizasyon
altına
almamız
gerekmiyor
buraya özellikle
dikkat
otomatik ömürlü
yerel değişkenleri
herhangi bir
şekilde
bir
kilit altında
kullanmak
gerekmiyor
neden
çünkü otomatik ömürlü
değişkenler
stekte
ve her
thread'in
ayrı bir
stek alanı
stek segmenti
var
birde
yine geçen dersimizden
hatırlayalım
thread
local
değişkenlerde
sadece o
thread'e özgü
değişkenlerde
değil mi
o thread
çalışmaya
başladığında
koşmaya
hayata
geliyorlardı
thread'in
koşması
bittikten
sonra
yani
join edildikten
sonra
artık o
thread local
değişken
arkadaşlar
hayatı
bitiyordu
onlar için
bir
senkronizasyon
mekanizmasına
gerek yok
yani
Necati
şunu diyebilir miyiz
buraya dikkatli izleyin
lütfen
diyelim ki
tam şöyle bir fonksiyon
içinde
sadece ve sadece
yerel değişkenler var
ya da
thread local
değişkenler kullanıyor
parametre değişkenleri de
otomatik
öbürlü değil mi
mesela
böyle bir fonksiyon
söz konusu
olduğunda
t türünden
x
herhangi bir tür
u türünden
y
burada da
bu değişkenlerin
kullanıldığı
sum
kod var
burada
tekrar tekrar
söylüyorum
bazen arkadaşlar
burayı yanlış
anlamış olabiliyor
burada da
bir mutex
kullanmak
gerektiğini
düşünüyor
burada herhangi bir şekilde
bir mutex
kullanmak
gerekiyor mu
cevap
hayır
ama bakın
burada
t türünden
g isimli
global bir değişken
olsaydı
ya da
örneğin
my class
sınıfının
efendim
t türünden
my class
sınıfının
x
ne diyelim
mc
isimli
statik ömürlü
yani
sınıfın statik
veri elemanı
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
ya da
buraya gelen
veri
referans semantiğiyle
ya da pointer semantiğiyle
gelseydi
o da olabilir
bakınız
e şimdi buraya
t yıldız
p tr
buraya gelen
veri
bir
pointer
adres
dolayısıyla
buraya gelen
adres
aynı nesnenin
adresi
olabilir
değil mi
bu durumda
referans semantiği
ya da pointer semantiği
bu şekilde
kullanılıyorsa
yine bir
koruma
gerekebilir
ama
tekrar tekrar
söyleyelim
eğer
hepsi okuma
amaçlı
akses amaçlı
erişiyorsa
hiçbir problem
yok
arkadaşlar
şimdi gelelim
bu
mutex
sınıflarına
biraz
baştan da söyleyeyim
biraz sabırlı
olmamız gerekiyor
yani sadece
bu
mutual
exclusion
sınıflarını
ve bunlarla
ilgili
arkadaşlar
İngilizcesiyle
guard
sınıflarını
yani
rayi
rapper
sınıflarını
bile görmemiz
bizim
5-6
saatimizi
alabilir
yani
biraz sabırlı
olmak
gerekiyor
ama
arkadaşlar
bundan da
kaçma
imkanımız yok
yani
şöyle söyleyeyim
mesela
modern
C++
ilk
çıktığında
yani
daha hiç kimse
kullanmadan
daha önce de
biliyorsunuz
oraya girmek
istemiyorum
yani
birden kabul edilmedi
bir
TR1 dönemi
vardı
bunları öğrenmek
için gerçekten
çok zaman
harcamak
gerekiyordu
çünkü
bütün
üyeler
yeni
özellikle
hani
daha önce
işletim
sisteminin
hapilerini
ya da
Unix
tarafında
Petra
kütüphanesini
kullananlar
buraya
alışmakta
biraz
zorluk
çekti
ama
zaman içinde
sürekli
kod okur
kod yazarsanız
oluşuyor
ama
yine de
şunu
söyleyelim
multi-threat
programlama
C++'ın
bütün
standart
araçlarını
kullansanız
dahi
arkadaşlar
karmaşık
yapıda
yani
multi-threat
bir uygulamada
burada
hiçbir hata
yok
demek için
o uygulamanın
belirli bir süre çalışması
ve çok iyi
test edilmesi
gerekiyor
çünkü öyle
durumlar var ki
mesela
düşünün
milyonda bir
olasılıkla
deadlock
oluştuğunu
düşünün
yani
milyonda bir
olasılık
ne demek
yani
bir milyon
iki milyon
üç milyon
kes karşınıza
çıkacak
ve tekrarlığına
gidir de
değil
testleri biliyorsunuz
testlere
aynı hatayı
tekrar edecek
bir senaryoyu
oluşturmanız da
mümkün değil
o yüzden
en iyi önlem
arkadaşlar
hata olmadan
yazarken
hatasız kod
yazmak için
ne kadar zor
olursa olsun
gayret göstermeyim
şimdi
bakınız
bizim
öncelikle
mutex
sınıflarımız
var
necati
neden
birden fazla
mutex
sınıfı var
şimdi bu
soru
başlangıçta
biraz bizi
zorlar
arkadaşlar
bu
farklı
mutex
sınıflarının
farklı
yetenekleri
var
ama tahmin
ediyorsunuz
değil mi
bir sınıfa
ne kadar fazla
yetenek
kazandırırsanız
o sınıf
türünden
nesneyle
işlem
yapmak
o yeteneklere
değil de
daha az
yeteneğe
sahip
benzer
başka sınıflar
türünden
nesnelerle
o işleri
yapmaya göre
daha yüksek
maliyeti
yani
Martan şöyle
diyebilirsiniz
o zaman
bunlar
farklı farklı
yeteneklere
sahipse
Necat burada
farklı yetenek
derken
neyi
kastediyorsun
mesela
arkadaşlar
TimeMutex'te
StudMutex'te
olmayan
fonksiyon
ya da fonksiyonlar
var
yani
TimeMutex'e
çağırabileceğim
ama
mutex sınıfı
nesneleriyle
çağıramayacağım
fonksiyonlar
var
ama o fonksiyonlara
ihtiyacım yoksa
minimal
StudMutex
sınıfını
kullanmalıyım
yani
burada
daha baştan
çok temel
bir ilkeyi
hemen konuşmamız
gerekiyor
nedir bu ilke
StudMutex
işini görüyorsa
yani
minimal
interfejse
sahip
burada
bir numarada
gösterdiğim
StudMutex
işini görüyorsa
asla
diğerlerini
kullanma
hem
okuyanı
yanıltırsın
okuyan
böylece
oradaki
daha fazla
yeteneklerin
kullanılacağına
yönelik bir
ipucu
olarak
algılar
o türden
örneğin
gidip de
recursive
timed
mutex
efendim
kullanmanızı
o yüzden
okuyanı da
doğru bilgilendirmek için
minimal
StudMutex'i
kullanacaksınız
arkadaşlar
mesela
timed
mutex'te
önce şöyle
macro düzeyde
bakalım
bunların hepsini
göreceğiz ama
mesela
timed
mutex'te
olmayan ne var
örnek
sadece
bunların arasındaki
farkı
biraz gönderme
yapmak için
an
mutex'te
bir mutex'i
arkadaşlar
belirli bir süre boyunca
kilitlemeye çalışma
örneğin yeteneği var
mutex'te öyle bir şey yok
mutex'te
sadece ne yapabiliyorsunuz
kilitlemek için
lag fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
kilitleyebilirse
kilitliyor
mutex'e alıyor
ediniyor
hepsini aynı anlamda
kullanıyorum
ve diğerlerini
bloke edilmesini
sağlıyor
unlock fonksiyonuyla da
arkadaşlar
ne yapıyorsunuz
mutex'i
bırakıyorsunuz
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
yani
minimal bir
interfejsi var
birazdan göreceğiz
ama
timed mutex'te
örneğin
belirli bir
süre
mutex'i
edinmeye çalış
edinirsen
kilitle
edinemezsen
yoluna
devam et
yani
rule döndüren
bir
duration
isteyen
ya da bir
time point
isteyen
neden
bir duration
bir de
time point
iki seçenek
veriyor
standart kütüphane
hep böyle durumlarda
duration olan
belirli bir
duration
süre boyunca
kilidi edinmeye
çalışıyor
mesela diyelim ki
10 milisaniye
boyunca
kilidi edinmeye
çalışıyor
edinirse
kilitliyor
giriyor kritik bölgeye
edinemezse
yoluna
devam ediyor
yani
bloke olmuyor
ama
stud mutex'te
başka bir şansımız
yok
edinirse
arkadaşlar
diğer
threadler
bloke
olacak
ya da edinemezsek
biz
bloke
olacağız
işte
öyle durumlar
var ki
bazı durumlarda
da
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
bazı durumlarda
da
biz
belirli
örneğin bir
fonksiyon içinde
bir
thread'i
mutex'i
birden fazla
kez
kilitlememiz
gerekiyor
yani
aynı
mutex'i
kilitledik
bir daha
kilitliyoruz
e tabi
tahmin ediyorsunuz
ne kadar
kilitlersek
o kadar
kilidi
kez
açmamız
gerekiyor
özellikle
a
rekörsif
fonksiyonlarda
b
sınıfların
üye
fonksiyonlarının
birbirini
çağırması
durumunda
arkadaşlar
böyle bir
rekörsif
yani
birden fazla
kez
kilitlenebilen
mutex'e
ihtiyacımız
oluyor
rekörsif
mutex'in de
özetle
hikayesi
böyle
rekörsif
timed
mutex
tahmin ediyorsunuz
hem
tekrar tekrar
kilitlenme
özelliğine
sahip
ama
aynı zamanda
süreyle
ya da
time point
de
yine
kilitleyebilirsen
bu kadar
süre içinde
ya da
bu time point
de kadar
kilitleyebilirsen
kilitle
yoksa
blok olmadan
yoluna
devam et
bunu
sağlayabiliyorsunuz
burada
arkadaşlar
5 ve
6'daki
mutex'ler
yani
mutex sınıfları
bunlar
görece olarak
C++'a
geç eklendi
shared
mutex
ve shared
timed
mutex
bunların da
aslında çok daha
önce
eklenmesi
gerekiyordu
esprisi şu
biraz karmaşık
ama yine de
biraz
ipucu verin
arkadaşlar
öyle uygulamalar
var ki
veriye
okuma amaçlı
akses amaçlı
erişme
çok daha fazla
ama set amaçlı
erişim
çok daha az
yani örneğin
bir thread
sadece
ne yapıyor
diyelim
veriyi
set ediyor
ona
writer
thread
deniyor
genelde
fakat
o writer
thread
tarafından
set edilen
veriyi
akses amaçlı
çok daha fazla
sayıda
thread kullanıyor
mesela 12 tane
thread olduğunu
düşünün
11'inin
varlık
nedeni
ya da
çalışma biçimi
o shared
data'yı
sadece
read access'le
okuma amaçlı
erişimle
kullanması
yani onların
o veri üstüne
bir değişiklik
yapma ihtiyacı yok
ama bir tanesi
sadece yazıyor
yine de bir
koruma gerekiyor
bu durumda
işte bu durumda
arkadaşlar
o yazma amaçlı
thread değil de
okuma amaçlı
threadlerden biri
kilidi aldığında
bütün o
paylaşımlı olarak
okuma amaçlı
threadlerin hepsi
o veriden
okuma yapabiliyor
bunu
sağlayan
böyle özel durumlarda
kullanılan
arkadaşlar bir
mutex
sınıfı
buraya kadar
umarım
bir fikir
vermiştir
şimdi
konuyu
alan bozkarı
hocam bu
mutexler
aynı anda
iki farklı
workload da
farklı
threadler
tarafından
kullanılabiliyor
mu
arkadaşlar
kesinlikle
burada
anlaşılması
gereken
nokta şu
tabii ki
kullanılabilir
abi
birden fazla
ayrı veriyi
tek bir
mutexte
koruyamazsınız
yani şuraya
dikkat
mesela diyelim ki
sizin
a
siyah
nesneniz var
b
global
bir değişkeniz
var
t türünden
g var
şimdi
siz bunlar
ayrı ayrı
fonksiyonlarda
kullanılıyorsa
arkadaşlar
o zaman
bunları
ayrı ayrı
mutexlerle
korumanız
gerekiyor
ama
şöyle bir durum
olsaydı
bunların
kullanıldığı
bütün
critical
section'larda
bunlar beraber
kullanılıyor
olsaydı
Alihan
o zaman
tek bir
mutexte
işimizi
görebilirdik
ama
Alihan
Bey'in
sorusunu
ben anladım
bu çok da
önemli bir
soru
Alihan
şunu
soruyor
diyor ki
mesela
fu isimli bir fonksiyon var
buraya dikkat
ve
bar isimli de bir fonksiyon var
klasik böyle olur ya
ve
baz isimli de bir fonksiyon var
takip edebiliyor muyuz
tamam
şimdi
burada bir critical section var
ama
bu critical section'lardaki
kod
aynı veriyi kullanıyor
aynı değişkeni kullanıyor
ben
ben şimdi
ben şimdi burada
tek bir mutext
nesnesi kullanarak
burayı
senkronize edebilir miyim
cevap
evet
ama
aynı değişken
kullanılıyorsa
anlaşılır değil mi
fonksiyonların
birbirinden
farklı olmasının
bir önemi
yok
sonuçta
arkadaşlar
mesela
mutexte kilitlediğiniz zaman
buradaki mutexte
yine
ortak
ne olacak
buraya gelen
kodda
aynı mutexte
kullanan
arkadaşlar
ne olacak
bloke olacak
anlaşıldı mı
ama tabi bu durumda
orası da yarım kaldı
oraya tekrar geri dönelim
çoğunlukla
bu tür uygulamalarda
bu mutexte
nesnelerinin
arkadaşlar
farklı farklı
threadler tarafından
kullanılıyor ya
bu durumda
bütün threadlerin
mutexte
nesnelerine
erişebilmesi
gerekiyor
yani
arkadaşlar
daha önce de
konuşmuştuk
şimdi
bazı durumlarda
evet biz global
değişkenleri
global state'i
genelde tercih etmiyoruz
ama mesela mutext
söz konusu olduğunda
bazı durumlarda
bu global state
gerekebiliyor
ya da fonksiyonların
hepsine
aynı mutext
nesnesini
referans
semantiğiyle
geçmeniz gerekiyor
evet
bu da
şöyle yapıların
oluşmasını
sağlıyor
a
birçok uygulamada
bu
ortak
paylaşımda
kullanılan
veriyi
senkronize
etmek için
global bir
mutext
değişkenliğin
kullanılması
ve
sınıfların
bu da çok yaygın
bir
veri elemanının
mutext olması
yani
bir sınıf
türünden
nesne için
sınıfın
üye fonksiyonları
çağrıldığında
o
üye fonksiyonlar
içinde
paylaşılan
verileri
senkronize
etmek için
arkadaşlar
onlar da
tipik olarak
sınıfın
data memberları
non-static
ya da
static
data memberları
bir ya da
birden fazla
üye fonksiyonu
içinde
senkronizasyon
sağlamamız
gerekiyor
o senkronizasyonu
sağlamak
için de
tipik olarak
sınıfın
mutext
türünden
non-static
bir
veri elemanı
oluyor
necati peki
soru
mutext'in
bir maliyeti
var mı
olmaz mı
arkadaşlar
mesela şöyle
bir şansımız
olsaydı
hem
veriyi
paylaşımlı
olarak
kullanıyoruz
ama
hiç de
mutext
kullanmıyoruz
işte
bakın
bu
bu tür
programlamaya
programlamanın
en zor
alanlarından
biri
ingilizce'de
belki
duymuşsunuzdur
terimi
lockfree
programming
deniyor
yani
kilitten
ari
arındırılmış
bir
yani bu ne demek
hiçbir thread
bloke olmuyor
program boyunca
threadler sürekli
ilerleme şansına
sahip
threadleri
hiçbir zaman
bloke etmiyorsunuz
böylece
işlemcinin
kaynaklarını
maksimum düzeyde
kullanabiliyorsunuz
evet
şimdi
biz o zaman
bir de
nelerden
bahsedelim
şöyle
önce makro
düzeyde
gidiyorum
sonra mikro
seviyeye
ineceğim
şimdi
makro
düzeyde
bilmemiz
gereken
bir şey
daha var
arkadaşlar
bakınız
tahmin edebileceğiniz
gibi
bu tür
durumlarda
thread'in
hani
join ve
detach
fonksiyonları
vardı
onlardan
birini
çağırmadığımız
zaman
thread
joinable
durumdayken
destructor
çağırıldığında
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağırılıyordu
herkes hatırlıyor
değil mi
o yüzden
baştan
eksik olan
sonra neyi
eklediler
benim daha sonra
yine bir
alt başlığım
olacak
jthread
sınıfına
eklediler
değil mi
jthread
aslında bir
rayı sınıfı
böyle sınıflara
diyoruz
yani
resource acquisition
is initialization
amaç
destructor'ın
burada
kaynağı
geri vermesi
işte
jthread'de
verilen
kaynak ne
ya da
sonlandırılan
kaynak
thread'in
join
fonksiyonunun
çağrındası
şimdi
burada da
şöyle bir
program var
arkadaşlar
burayı
dikkatli izleyin
burada da şöyle bir
problem var
şimdi diyelim ki
burası
critical section
ve
siz
kodu yazarken
burayı
koruma altına
almak için
arkadaşlar
burayı
koruma altına
almak için
burada
mtx'in
efendim
lag fonksiyonunu
çağırdınız
burada
ben genelde de
mutex nesnelerine
kolay takip edebilmeniz
için
mtx ismini
vereceğim
arkadaşlar
burada da
unlag fonksiyonunu
çağırdınız
bakın şimdi
buradaki bir
kod
exception
provide ise
if
bla bla
ve
prove
exception
sembolik olarak
yazıyorum
kodu
o zaman
bu exception
yakalansa
dahi
aynı
arkadaşlar
word load
içinde
ee
programın
akışı
mesela burayı da
bir try
blue altına
aldığımızı
düşünelim
içine aldığımızı
try
takip edin
sembolik yazıyorum
ama en azından
anlattığım
anlaşılıyor
burada da
try
blue'unun
catch
blue'u var
peki
soru
işte burada
try
blue'u içinde
gönderilen
exception'i yakaladık
tamam
programın akışı
devam edecek
ama
bir problem var
anlak
çağrılmadı
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
işte bu
problemin en kolay
çözümü ne
öyle bir
rayı sınıfı
olsun ki
bu rayı
sınıfı
bir
mutex
nesnesine
sarmalasın
repelsin
burada sarmalasın
demekte
kastettiğim ne
tipik olarak
referans
semantiğiyle
eleman olarak
alıyor
ve
bu
rayı sınıfının
arkadaşlar
destraktör'ı
çağrıldığında
destraktör'ı da
mutex'in
anlak
fonksiyonunu
çağırsın
böylece
arkadaşlar
klasik tema
değil mi
böylece
siz
böyle bir
rayı
sınıfı
böyle sınıfları
guard sınıfları
da deniyor
böyle bir
guard sınıfı
türünden
nesneyle
mutex'i
kullanırsanız
o zaman
a
artık
anlak
fonksiyonunu
çağırmanıza
gerek kalmayacak
onunla uğraşmayacaksınız
çünkü
en büyük risklerden biri de
anlak'ı çağırmanın
unutulması olabilir
b
exception
throw ederek
ilgili
try
bloğundan
çıkarsa
bu durumda da
ne deniyordu
onu hatırlayınız
stack unwinding
süreciyle
otomatik ömürlü
bizim guard nesnemizin
hayatı bitecek
arkadaşlar
stack unwinding
sürecinde
ve
destructor'ı
çağrıldığında
yine
mutex'i
unlock edecek
eğer bakın
buradan
mutex
burası çok çok
önemli
mesela şöyle olsaydı
ne olurdu
arkadaşlar
girdi buraya
guard yok
lock fonksiyonu
çağrıldı
e buraya
başka threadler de
girecek
değil mi
tamam
şimdi o threadler
bloke oldu
e burada
exception gönderildi
unlock burada
unlock'ı
görmedi
programın
akışı
buraya geldi
o zaman
bir daha
bu mutex'i
unlock etme
şansı
var mı
cevap
hayır
bu durumda
ya da
çok daha karmaşık
bir kod yazmanız
gerekiyor
hayır derken
onunla uğraşmaya
ne gerek var
işte böyle bir
rayı sınıfı
olsaydı
hiçbir problem
olmayacaktı
işte
dört tane de
sınıf var ki
bunlar
kendisi mutex
değil
bunlar bir şekilde
mutex'i alıp
bu mutex'i
sarmalayıp
ingilizce
wrap edip
arkadaşlar
destructorları
tarafından
mutex'in
gerektiğinde
yani unlock edilmemişse
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorlar
böylece
exception safety
sağlanıyor
birden fazla
thread kullanılmasına
rağmen
artı
artık
unlock fonksiyonunu
hani burada
belki yine
İngilizce'de kullanıyor
bize tuhaf geliyor ama
manuel
çağırmak
gerekmiyor
yani burada
manuel derken
aslında daha doğru
terim
explicit olarak
mutex'in
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağırmıyorsunuz
bir tane mi
sadece
gard sınıfı var
keşke öyle
olsaydı
öğrenme yükü
çok az olurdu
arkadaşlar
yine
nasıl
mutex'lerin
farklı mutex
sınıflarının
farklı yetenekleri
varsa
aynı şekilde
farklı
rayı
sınıflarının
yani
mutex'i
sarmalayan
benim
gard
dediğim
sınıflarında
yine
farklı
yeteneğe
sahip
ayrı ayrı
sınıflar var
bunlar
arkadaşlar
neler
hemen
isimlerini
bir kere de
ezberlersiniz
en çok
kullanılan
lock gard
sınıfı
nasıl
mutex
sınıflarından
stud mutex
minimalist
mutex
sınıfıysa
lock gard
da
minimalist
arkadaşlar
gard sınıfı
ama
ondan sonra
en yetenekli
gard sınıfı
arkadaşlar
unique lock
şimdi diyeceksiniz ki
ne olabilir ki
bunun kapasitesi
arkadaşlar son derece
basit
bakın
lock gard o kadar
basit ki
mutex'i ediniyor
unique ptr ile
bu konunun
doğrudan bir alakası
yok
bir yanlış
anlamı olmasın
hiç
unique ptr'yi
şimdilik
karıştırmayalım
ama
ilerleyen
dakikalarda
ben
yine sorunuza
daha ayrıntılı
cevap verim
ama tabi zaten
ben bunları
anlattığım zaman
sorunuz da
otomatik olarak
düşecek
böyle bir soruya
gerek yokmuş
diyeceksiniz
peki
evet
arkadaşlar
unique ptr ile
benzerliği var
yani unique ptr ile
ha şimdi anladım
rasul
tamam özür dilerim
ben sorunuzu
yanlış anlamışım
diyor ki
unique ptr
şimdi anlaşıldığı
soru gayet güzel
rasul bey diyor ki
unique ptr ile
ben sadece
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesnenin
hayatını kontrol etmek
zorunda değilim ki
orada
hani custom
deleter kullanarak
arkadaşlar
bir kaynağı
geri verebiliyordum
burada da
unique ptr'yi
kullanabilir miyim
dostlu isterseniz
cevabım
evet
şimdi soruyu anlayınca
cevabım
evet
ama
ne gerek var ki
burada
sırf bu iş için
oluşturulmuş
hazır
kullanabileceğimiz
bu guard
sınıfları
hem kullanması
daha kolay
hem derdini
daha iyi anlatıyor
yani kesinlikle
öyle bir
unique ptr'ı
bir custom
deleter ile
sadece
mutex'in
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağırmak için
kullanmaya gerek yok
demek istiyorum
mesela aradaki
fark ne
arkadaşlar
çok basit
mesela
log guard
çok basit
mutex'i alıyor
kilitliyor
ve
destruktör'ı da
unlock ediyor
yani bunun dışında
neredeyse hiçbir
interfej yok
bir tane
onu konuşacağız
ama
unique lock
arkadaşlar
kilidi edinmeden
hayata başlayabiliyor
birden fazla
lock
fonksiyonunu
çağırabiliyor
yani aynı
unique lock
guard nesnesiyle
onun
sarmaladığı
mutex'i
birden fazla
kez
lock
unlock
yapabiliyorsunuz
efendim
kilitlemeden
edinip
daha sonra
unique lock'ın
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
daha sonra
kilitleyebiliyorsunuz
yani
unique lock
lock
card'ın
sağlamadığı
birçok
olanağı
sağlıyor ki
ileride göreceğimiz
bazı başka
konular var
örneğin
condition
variable
bitredden
bitrede
veri iletme
mekanizmalarından
biri
bu
condition
variable
kısmında
işte bizim
unique lock
guard sınıfını
kullanmamız
mecburi
hale
gelecek
evet
yani bu
ikisi
özellikle çok
önemli
lock
card
minimal
unique lock
da
hani minimalin
tersi ne olabilir
maksimal
en fazla
interfejsi
sunan
ama
bunun dışında
iki tane daha var
biri
arkadaşlar
siplaf
pass 17
ile
bileklenen
aslında
lock
card
çoğunlukla
ilave
bir
maliyet
sağlamayan
ama
lock
card
kullanıldığı
bazı
senaryolarda
işimizi
çok daha
kolaylaştıran
arkadaşlar
bir sınıf
hatta
birçok
kişi
şöyle
düşünüyor
birçok
developer
şöyle
düşünüyor
c
plus
pass 17
ile
scop
lock
eklendikten
sonra
ben diyor
lock
card
hiç
kullanmıyorum
çünkü
scop
lock
card
gibi
kullandığımda
ilave
bir
maliyet
getirmiyor
ama
bazı
durumlarda
deadlock
kaçınmak
için
scop
lock
verdiği
bazı
garanti
ya da
garantiler
var
işte
efendim
bir de
yine
daha
sonradan
eklenen
shared lock
sınıfı
var
arkadaşlar
shared lock
sınıfı
da
tahmin
ediyorsunuz
shared
müyoteksi
ile
birlikte
kullanılan
efendim
card
sınıfı
şimdi
burada
isimlendirmede
de
biraz
tuhaflık
olduğu için
programcılar
ben dahil
ilk başladığımda
öğrenmekte de
zorluk çekiyorlar
neden
ya isim
mesela şöyle
olsaydı
lock'a
hepsinin sonu
guard'la bitseydi
ya da
hepsinin sonu
lock'la bitseydi
o zaman
daha kolay olurdu
ama bakın
aslında
birinin sonunda
guard ismi var
diğerlerinde
lock var
ama
sonuçta özünde
bunların
hepsi
mutex'leri
sarmalayan
rayı sınıfları
deniz
akkuş
seviyorlar
shared
ve unique
isimlerini
bir de
weak lock
koysalarmış
tam olacakmış
unique lock
yakışıyor
neden biliyor musunuz
tahmin edebilen
var mı
neden burada
unique lock
demişler
çünkü
diğer
örneğin
lock card
movable
değil
ama
unique lock
movable
yani
bir koddan
bir koda
aşıma
semantiğiyle
unique lock'ı
aktarabiliyorsunuz
burada öyle benzetme
yapmışlar
deniz
yani
nasıl
unique
ptr
movable
bir sınıfsa
bir dinamik
ömürlü
nesnenin
tek sahibi ise
unique lock'ı da
nasıl düşüneceksiniz
mutex'in
tek sahibi
ama
başka bir
unique lock
nesnesine
sahip olduğu
mutex'i
devredebiliyor
benim bu mutex'te
işim bitti
ama sen bu mutex'i
kullanabilirsin
anlamında
arkadaşlar
aşıma
semantiğiyle
kullanılabildiği
için
unique lock
ismini
vermişler
evet
peki
yani yine de
isimlendirme
biraz eleştiriye
tabi
onu
söylemek
gerekiyor
şimdi o zaman
biz
mutex sınıfıyla
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
burada
bütün mesele
kritik kodu
bir mutex'te
korumak
arkadaşlar bakın
olabilecek en basit
kodu yazalım
çok dikkatli izleyin
şimdi
diyelim ki
bizim bir tane
global değişkenimiz var
mesela
unsigned
özellikle böyle yazıyorum ki
çok büyük değerleri de
tutabilsin
long long
count
ya da
cn't
sıfır
değeriyle
hayatta başlasın
ve bizim
bir fonksiyonumuz var
void
hep ne olur
fonksiyonların
ismi böyle durumlarda
full
bu isimde
bir fonksiyonumuz var
ve
bu isimde
fonksiyonumuz da
bir tane
döngü olsun
mesela bu döngü
arkadaşlar
hatta döngü değişkeni de
unsigned long
türünden olsun
ya da şöyle de
yazabilirim
değil mi
arkadaşlar
auto
i
eşittir
ul
l
efendim
i küçük
1 milyon
asayi long
tabi 1 milyon için
ihtiyaç olmayacak ama
bakın bakın
artı artı
i
burada da
counter değişkeninin
değerini
bir
arttıralım
count
count değişkeninin
değerini
bir arttıralım
şimdi
thread başlık dosyasını
dahil edeyim
arkadaşlar
iostream
başlık dosyasını
dahil edeyim
bakın bakın
bakın
şimdi
tipik bir
data race
oluşturacağız
4 tane thread
oluşturalım
ya da 5 tane
stud
thread
p1
efendim
iş yükü
ben türkçe şu terimi seviyorum
word load
word load olarak
neyi verelim
fu'yu verelim
t2'ye de fu'yu verelim
t3'e de fu'yu verelim
arkadaşlar
t4'e de
fu'yu verelim
arkadaşlar
açık açık açık açık
burada bir
ne var
data race var
çünkü
aynı değişkeni
kullanıyor
bu
threadler
öyle değil mi
yani örneğin
bir thread
cnt değişkenini
kullanırken
başka bir thread de
yine yazma amaçlı
cnt
değişkenini
kullanıyor
bu durumda
işte uzun uzun
belki bir derse
onu da anlatırım
hani arka planda
neler oluyor
burada bir sürü
problematik durum var
çünkü tipik olarak
böyle değişkenlerin
değerinin değiştirilmesi
pek bir makine komutuyla
yapılmıyor
ileride atomik
değişkenler konusunda
göreceğiz
eğer atomik olsaydı
yani buradaki
count değişkeni
atomik özellikte
bir değişken
olsaydı
onu ayrıca
anlatacağım
zaten
başka bir
senkronizasyona
ihtiyaç
olmayacaktı
şimdi bunları
join edelim
p1
join
t2
t3
t4
join
arkadaşlar
bakın bir şey daha
söyleyeceğim
şimdi ben
ilk kodu
böyle yazdım
ama
hem vakit
kazanmak için
hem de
c++20
desteğiniz varsa
zaten artık
doğrusu güzeli
bu kabul ediliyor
ama şunu bir bitireyim
ve buradan
çıktıktan sonra da
efendim
counter
değişkeninin
mıydı
cnt
isimli
değişkenin
değerini
yazdıralım
bandar alalım
evet
ha
demin söyleyeceğimi
şimdi söyleyeyim
şimdi
bu ilk kodu
böyle çalıştıralım
ama
bundan sonra
böyle yazmak
yerine
arkadaşlar
burayı
dikkatli izleyin
bunları
stu thread nesnesi
yapmak yerine
jthread yapacağım
yalnız burada
bir şeye dikkat
yani kodu
bundan sonra
her defasında
kodu açıklama
ihtiyacı olmasın
diye bir kere
açıklayayım
bundan sonra
tekrar tekrar
açıklamak
gereği duymayayım
arkadaşlar
bu kodu
böyle bıraksaydım
jthread nesnesinin
destructor'ı
join edecek
değil mi
peki
jthread nesnelerinin
destructor'ı
nerede çağrılacak
jvap
programın akışı
buraya geldiğinde
deniz öyle değil mi
programın akışı
buraya geldiğinde
jthread nesnelerinin
destructor'ı
çağrılacak
ama bir dakika
o zaman
main thread de
devam ediyor
main thread çalışır
bitebilir
değil mi
o yüzden
ya kodu
böyle yazıyorum
çünkü burada
artık
arkadaşlar
bu joinler
çalışana kadar
bu
thread
bizim ana thread
bloke olmak zorunda
değil mi
ancak yollar ne zaman
devam edecek
sonunca oyun çağrısından
sonra
yani ben
count değişkeninin
değerini
standart
output'a
yazdırdığımda
artık neden
eminim
Alihan
bu thread'lerin
hepsinin
koşup
işini tamamladığımdan
eminim
Yiğit derste mi
bu konuda
onun bir sorusu
vardı
onu konuşmuştuk
bakalım
Yiğit yokmuş
bugün derste
evet
Yiğit inceden
bahsediyorum
tamam
kayıttan
benim sesimi
duysun o zaman
peki
şimdi
böyle durumda
hani o thread'lerin
çalışmasının
bitmesinden sonra
main'deki bir kodu
çalıştırmaktan
emin olmak için
tahmin edin
ne yapacağım
buraya
suni bir
nested
blok
oluşturacağım
neden
arkadaşlar
evet
neden
çünkü
burada
deteşte de
o deteşi
ayrıca
tekrar
oraya geri dönüp
kodurtmamız
gerekiyor
ama
deteşte de
tabi o
program var
şimdi
sadece
anlamanızı
istediğim
bu nested
bloku
neden
koydu
çünkü
bu nested
bloku
bu da
bir blok
olduğu için
buradaki
c-thread
sınıfı
türünden
t1
t2
t3
t4
nesneleri
bunlar
otomatik ömürlü
nesneleri
olduğu için
burada
destructorları
çağrılacak
çağrıldığı
zaman
bunlar
arkadaşlar
join
edilecekler
Alihan
anlaşıldı mı
dolayısıyla
yine burada
üstteki
nested
bloktan
dolayı
ben
artık
bütün
threadlerin
kodunun
çalışması
bittikten
sonra
22.
satırdaki
kodun
çalışmasından
çalışacağından
eminim
arkadaşlar
şimdi işte
burada
data race
var ve
tanımsız
davranış
arkadaşlar
evet
bir yerde
sentax
düzeltelim
ve derleyip
çalıştıralım
Necat
neyi
göstermeye
çalışıyorsun
burada
şunu
göstermeye
çalışıyorum
arkadaşlar
normalde
gerçekten
bütün
threadler
bütün işlemlerini
yapsaydı
her thread
count değişkenini
1 milyon kez
arttırmış
olacaktı
1 milyon kez
arttırınca da
toplam
yani 22.
satırdaki
printout'a
programın
akışı
geldiğinde
count'un
değerinin
efendim
4 milyon
olması
gerekirdi
ama şimdi
bakalım
1 milyon
60 bin
bilmem
kaç
tabii ki
deterministik
değil
başka bir şey
de olabilirdi
sonuçta
tanımsız
davranış
ama şimdi
bakın
iki farklı
şey yapalım
soru 1
Alihan
bu soru
size
stud
mutex
mtx
başlık dosyasını
dahil edelim
burada
belki sevmediğim
bir şey
daha var
göreceksiniz
arkadaşlar
bakınız
şöyle bir
başlık dosyası
daha var
shared mutex
yani
daha sonra
eklendiği için
shared mutex'i
ayrı bir
header
yaptılar
yani sonuçta
bu da mutex'de
belki bunun da
mutex header'ında
olması
iyi olurdu
o zaman şöyle
diyelim
shared mutex
kullanmıyorsanız
o zaman
mutex
diğer bütün
bundan sonra
göreceğimiz
farklı mutex
sınıfları için
yeterli
ama
arkadaşlar
shared mutex için
ayrı bir
başlık dosyası var
şimdi bir tane
mutex
oluşturalım
stud
mutex
mtx
işte bakın
şimdi örnek üstünde
gittiğimiz zaman
birçok konuyu
birlikte görme
şansımız oluyor
tabi şimdi ben
şöyle hesap ettim
sadece bu
senkronizasyon
konusunda
arkadaşlar
yüzdeye yakın
örnek hazırlamışım
yani bunların
hepsinin şimdi
kodunu
burada yazmak
bazılarını
birlikte yazacağız da
mümkün olmaz
o zaman
300 saatte
bitiremeyiz
o yüzden bazı
kodları böyle
birlikte yazacağız
o yazdığımız
kodlar üstünde
sorulara cevap vereceğim
ya da ben size
sorular soracağım
ama bazılarını da
basır
yazdım
daha önce
kitabıma koydum
kodlardan
alacağım
şimdi arkadaşlar
bakın
birinci soru
mutex'in
lakı
unlakı
şimdi birinci soru
bu kodda
tanımsız davranış
var mı
cevap
evet
yine bu sorularım
başlıyor
bu kodda tanımsız
davranış var mı
cevap
hayır
çünkü senkronize
ama
soru 2
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
senkronizasyon
iyi mi kötü mü
onu tartışmıyoruz
değil mi
Oğuzhan Bey
yoksa
bakınız
bu ne demek
yani
ilk gelen thread
kilidi ilk alan thread
bu döngüyü
bitirene kadar
bir yerlere
bloke olacak
bekleyecek
burada
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani onlar
ilerleme
kaydetmeyecek
buradan şöyle bir
ileriye doğru
gönderme de yapalım
arkadaşlar
en temel ilkelerden biri
critical section'ı
olduğunca dar tutmak
yani critical section'ı
ne kadar geniş tutarsanız
oradaki kodlar
sadece
tek bir thread
tarafından
koşturulacak
bittikten sonra
öbür thread
gelecek
dolayısıyla
critical section'da
olmayabilecek
kodu
boş yere
critical section'ı
içine
almayın
arkadaşlar
ya da orayı critical section
yapmayın
şimdi
derleyip çalıştırıyorum
ve
görüyorsunuz
4 milyon
şimdi soru
arkadaşlar
böyle yazmak
yerine
izleyin
şöyle yazsaydım
aa
yine bir problem
olmaz
bakın verimden
falan bahsetmiyorum
yanlış anlaşılmasın
yani
efficiency
performance
vesaire
sorusu değil
tanımsız davranış
var mı
yoksa
27. satırda
çalışan
count değişkeninin
değerini yazdıran
kod
count değişkeninin
değerini yine
4 milyon
yazar mı
cevap
tabii ki
yazar
ama
bir dakika
şimdi artık
durum tamamen
değişti
değil mi
Cengiz Ambey
çünkü
1 milyon
kez dönen
döngünün
her turunda
sadece
bir kere
arttırmak için
senkronize
ediyorum
yani örneğin
şimdi
kafanızda
canlandırın
T1 geldi
T1'de
döngünün
ilk turu
arkadaşlar
burada
kilidi aldı
T2
T3
T4
bekleyecek
bu bırakacak
öbür
başka bir
thread'in
döngüsünden
orası
bir arttıracak
yani
bu iki
kodun da
aynı anlama
gelmesi
aynı miktarda
lock
unlock
fonksiyonunun
çağrıldığı
anlamına
şüphesiz
gelmiyor
ama
arkadaşlar
tabii ki
böyle olacak
peki
bir soru daha
kodu böyle yazsaydım
takip edin
arkadaşlar
kodu böyle yazsaydım
ne olurdu
buradaki
mutex nesnesi
otomatik ömürlü
arkadaşlar
bakın
anlaşıldı değil mi
aynı mutex nesnesini
kullanmadığınız sürece
bir
ne
söz konusu değil
senkronizasyon
şimdi
aslında
tek basit örnek
üstünden
birçok soruya da
cevap verme
şansına sahip
peki
bir soru daha
bir mutex'i
global yaptım
aslında
Alihan
sizin sorduğunuz
soru sanıyorum
şimdi
benim soracağım
soru olacak
bir mutex'i
global yaptım
efendim
burada
hatta
yine
mutex'in
iyi ya da kötü
anlamında
söylemiyorum
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
burada
mutex'in
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
ve
burada
ikinci bir fonksiyon
daha var
bu da
bar fonksiyonu
üçüncü bir fonksiyon
daha var
bas fonksiyonu
bu
bar
bas
arkadaşlar
izleyin
iyice
abartalım
dört tane
kopya
buradan devam
edelim
e beş
altı
yedi
sekiz
tahmin ediyorsunuz
değil mi?
ne yazacağım?
siz de bu arada
düşünün
sorunun ne olduğunu
herkes tahmin ediyor
bar
evet
necet niye şöyle
yapmıyorsun?
dur niye yapmıyorum ki?
bas
ama şurası
mecbur
dokuz
on
on bir
on iki
evet
şimdi soru
Alihan ben tahmin ettim
sorunuzu anladım
şöyle ekrana çok
yayıldı ama
şöyle yapalım
önce main'e bir bakın
dört tane thread
foo'yu çalıştırıyor
bar'ı çalıştırıyor
efendim
dört tane thread
de
bazı çalıştırıyor
ve
burada
thread'ler
koşmayı bitirecek
jthread olduğu için
aynı
new text
nesnesini
kullanıyorum
date aralık
var mı?
yoksa
iyi mi
kötü mü
sorusu
tekrar söylüyorum
değil
iyi mi
kötü mü
sorusu
kesinlikle
değil
problem var mı?
ya da şöyle sorayım
programın akışının
bu noktaya geldiğinde
derleyicinin ne olduğundan
bağımsız
on iki milyon
yaz
on iki mi oluyor?
dört sekiz
on iki oluyor değil mi?
arkadaşlar
on iki milyon
olma garantisi
var mı?
var
çünkü aynı
mutex'i kullanıyorum
evet
arkadaşlar bakın
on iki milyon
tesadüfe değil
sizde de öyle
olmak zorunda
şimdi soruyu
yine değiştiriyorum
arkadaşlar
mutex
mtx
birinci fonksiyon
birinci mutex'i
kullanıyor
ikinci fonksiyon
ikinci mutex'i
kullanıyor
üçüncü fonksiyonda
üçüncü mutex'i
kullanıyor
hadi bakalım
bu biraz daha zor
undefined behavior
var mı yok mu?
cevap
arkadaşlar
undefined behavior
var
bakın bu hata da
çok yapılıyor
takip ettik
ve aynı mutex
olmadığı sürece
hiçbir şekilde
bir senkronizasyon
garantisi
yok
işte
alhan sanıyorum
sorunuz buydu
ben de sorunuza
cevap vermiş oldum
bravo
aynı anda
hem bar
hem bas
cnt'ye erişebilir
burada bir
senkronizasyon yok
efendim
şimdi
yavaş yavaş
artık örnekleri
arttıralım
bakın
printblock diye
bir fonksiyon var
printblock fonksiyonu
birinci parametreye
döngünün kaç kez
döneceği
değeri
gönderilecek
örneğin
main fonksiyonu
içinde
çalıştırılan
threadlerde
fonksiyonun
birinci parametresine
50 değerinin
gönderildiğini
görüyorsunuz
thread içinde
aynı
ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
bu döngü
50 kez dönecek
her bir thread için
söylüyorum
50 kez dönecek
ve 50 kez
döndüğünde
burada
her thread
buraya geldiğinde
5 milisaniye
bloke olacak
sonra
c'nin
değerini yazacak
arkadaşlar
evet
burada
herhangi bir şekilde
bir
senkronizasyon yok
necad niye
senkronizasyon
gereksin ki
cevap
see out için
senkronizasyon
gerekiyor
şimdi dikkat
ama
bu
stream nesneleri için
şöyle bir
garanti veriyor
standart
tıfane
karakter
bazında
herhangi bir şekilde
bir problem yok
yani burada
mesela soru şu olsaydı
burada
undefined
behavior var mı
bu
o stream
sınıfına ilişkin
özel bir durum
tekrar söylüyorum
burada undefined
behavior var mı
yok
ama
arkadaşlar
bu
karakterlerin
hangi sırayla
yazılacağı
konusunda da
bir garanti yok
yani
diyelim ki
bir thread
yıldızı bastı
ondan sonra
bir thread
doları bastı
artıyı bastı
böyle olabilir
bu
herhangi bir şekilde
deterministik değil
ama o stream için
herhangi bir şekilde
arkadaşlar
ne yok
orada
bir problem
yok
ama
bakınız
ekran çıktısı
biraz yayılmış durumda
ama
tahmin ediyorum
görebiliyorsunuz
böyle bir
durum
oluştu
bir şeyde
dikkat edin
şuradaki
new line da
arkadaşlar
dikkat ederseniz
bakın şimdi
new line'lar
böyle dağılmış
evet
ama şöyle
olsaydı
şimdi örneği
tamamen
değiştirelim
stud
mutex
mtx
hep aynı
ismi
kullanacağım
ve
efendim
mtx
lock
anlar
hiçbir zaman
ben
aksini
söylemediğim
sürece
hiçbir
soru
verim
sorusu
değil
arkadaşlar
ve
mutex
spashtik dosyasını da
dahil ettik
ve şimdi bakın
hatta hatta
bundan sonraki örnekler
şimdi kopyalı yapıştır olduğu için
böyle olmuş
burada mesela
c-tread'i kullanmamdı
hiçbir engel yok
kullanabiliriz her yerde
c-tread'i kullanabilirim
eğer
c++
20 desteği varsa
şimdi ne değişti
Alihan
Deniz
Oğuzhan
ne değişti
artık ne garanti altında
50 tane
yıldız
dolar
50 tane
artı
ünlem
her biri
bir satıra
yazılacak
bu garanti altında
şimdi
Necati ilk kere
lakı çağırdım
düzeltiyorum
anlak
olmalı
Cengiz Han
teşekkür ediyorum
evet
arkadaşlar
bu artık garanti altında
değil mi
orada 5000 saniye
bekleme olmasına rağmen
bakın
bu şekilde çalışması
garanti altında
çünkü
niçin
diğer tread'ler
burada bekleyecek
ama tabi
şu sorunun cevabı
yine
hayır
burada
soruyu sorayım
cevabını önce söyledim
burada
önce bir satır
yıldız
sonra bir satır
dolar
artı
yani buradaki sırayla
satırların
çıkma garantisi
var mı
hayır
o deterministik
değil
yani mesela
bakarsanız
yıldız
dolar
artı
ünlem
ama bu
kesinlikle
garanti altında
değil
yani bunu
güvenerek
ne yapamayız
kod yazamayız
arkadaşlar
şimdi
aslında ileri bir konu
ama ben ilk örneğini
vermek istiyorum
şimdi veri yapıları
söz konusu olduğunda
veri yapılarının da
senkronizasyonuna
çoğu zaman
multi-thread çalışacaksa
ihtiyacı var
mesela bir mülakata girdiniz
mülakatta şöyle bir soru sordular
vektör sınıfını
kullanıyorsunuz
ama birden fazla
sınıf
paylaşımlı olarak
aynı
stod vektör nesnesini
kullanıyor
peki
bu
kendiliğinden
thread safe midir
bu terimde
en çok kullanılan
terim
thread safe
yani thread safe
olması ne demek
arkadaşlar
şu anlamda
kullanılıyor
thread güvenli
yani ne
anlamda
kullanılıyor
yani öyle bir program ki
a
multi-thread
çalışmasına rağmen
paylaşımlı
değişkenler
olmasına rağmen
bir kere
data race
den
ahri
data race
yok
ama aynı zamanda
şunu da kapsıyor
deadlock da
olmaması gerekiyor
yani deadlock
livelock gibi
problemler de
yok
yani threadlerin
birden fazla
thread'in olmasına rağmen
herhangi bir şekilde
runtime'da
garanti bir şekilde
problem oluşturulacak
bir durum yok
yani thread safe
olması
efficiency'nin
ya da performansın
az
çok
yüksek
vesaire
olup olmamasıyla
doğrula
ilgili değil
evet
şimdi o zaman
soruya devam
edelim
mesela
diyelim ki
bir
vektör nesnemiz var
stud
vektörün
int açılımı
ibek
ve bu vektör nesnesini
böyle ya da böyle
birden fazla
thread
yine
en az biri
yazma amaçlı
olarak
kullanıyor
buraya dikkat
sizin bu durumda
ibek'i
için
yine
senkronizasyon
mekanizmalarından
birini kullanmanız
mecburi mi
cevap
evet
arkadaşlar bu arada
yanlış anlaşılmasın
bu sorunun cevabı
hayır da olabilirdi
bu sorunun cevabının
evet olması
tabii ki
standart kütüphanenin
tercihi
ve tabii ki
iyi bir tercih
düşünsenize
standart kütüphane
multi thread
bu konteynerların
çalışmasını
garanti altına
alsaydı
o zaman
multi thread değil
ayrı ayrı
yani single thread
o fonksiyon sürekli
çalışıyorsa
boş yere
senkronizasyon
maliyeti olurdu
değil mi
ama şimdi
bu konuyu
ileride son
derslere
gelecek herhalde
o özellikle
algoritmaların
paralel
çalıştırılmasıyla
ilgili
biraz burada
bir şeye dikkat
şu garanti
veriliyor
yani örneğin
threadlerden
diyelim ki
bu vektörde
10 bin tane
öğe var
buraya dikkat
ve
4 tane thread
çalışıyor
Oğuzhan
Cengizhan
threadlerden biri
ilk 2500
öğeyi
diğer thread
ondan sonraki
öğeyi
3.
thread
yani
7500'e
kadar olan
öğeyi
son thread
de
son 2500
öğeyi
kullanıyor
ama
bu threadler
beraber koşuyor
aynı vektör
üstünde
işlem yapıyor
arkadaşlar
bu arada
yanlış anlaşılmasını
ekleme
vesaireden
bahsetmiyorum
ben oradaki
verileri
set
ya da
read
access
ya da
set
amaçlı
kullanıyor
bu durumda
senkronizasyon
gerekiyor mu
mesela bu sorunun
cevabı da
arkadaşlar
evet ya da
hayır olabilirdi
ama
STL bu
garantiyi
veriyor
anlaşıldı
değil mi
STL
bu garantiyi
veriyor
yani bu şekilde
vektörü
kullanırsanız
yine
senkronize
etmeniz
gerekmiyor
çünkü ayrı ayrı
bellek alanlarında
yani aynı değişken
olmasına rağmen
arkadaşlar
paylaşımlı
bu şekilde
kullanma
şansınız var
diyor
bunu da
o konuya gelince
göreceğiz
evet
şimdi
buraya dikkat
ama
diyelim ki
bizim vektörü
güvenli bir şekilde
ya da bu vektör
olmak zorunda
değil herhangi bir
arkadaşlar
konteyner olabilir
güvenli bir şekilde
birden fazla
thread
onların
üye fonksiyonlarını
ne yapıyor
çağırıyor
bu durumda
thread safe
olması için
arkadaşlar
ya o üye fonksiyonların
çağrıldığı
her yerde
client tarafı
client derken
vektörü
kullanan
kod
senkronizasyonunu
yapacak
ama
ikinci bir seçenek
daha var
sınıfın kendisi
senkronizasyonu
yapabilir
yani son derece
üye fonksiyonları
her birini
koruma altına
alırsanız
ki bu da
yine
ileri düzeyde
tekrar ele alınması
gereken bir konu
ama basitçe
şimdilik detayları
düşünmezsek
şöyle diyebiliriz
arkadaşlar
her bir
thread
özür dilerim
her bir üye fonksiyon
yaptığı işte
sınıfın
veri elemanı
ya da elemanlarını
bu şekilde
senkronize
ederse
kendi işlemlerini
10 tane
üye fonksiyonun
10 numara
bunu yaptığını
düşünelim
bu durumda
birden fazla
thread kullansa
dahi
sınıfın
bütün operasyonları
senkronize
edildiği için
client tarafı
herhangi bir şekilde
kendisi
client'ın
senkronizasyonla
uğraşmak zorunda
kalmayacak
burada bir terimi de
ilk defa
duyun diye söylüyorum
bu şekilde
çalışan sınıfların
bu senkronizasyon
biçimine
İngilizce'de
internal
sinkronizasyon
deniyor
yani internal
olması
class için
internal
sınıf bunu
kendi başına
anlediyor
anlamında
şimdi bu örneği
yine müsaadenizle
yapıştıracağım
çünkü sadece
bunu yazmam
herhalde
bizden
yarım saat
götürüldü
arkadaşlar bakın
şimdi
basit bir
internal
sinkronizasyon
örneği
arkadaşlar burada
tabi detay var
diyorum ya
sınıfın
normalde
private fonksiyonları
da olabilir
public fonksiyonları
mesela private fonksiyonlu
client'ların çağırması
söz konusu
olmadığına göre
orada başka bir şekilde
tasarım
yapılabilir
demek istiyorum
bakın şimdi
aslında
evet
tamam
aslında bir şeye
dikkat edin
çok da öğretici bir örnek
arkadaşlar bakalım
şimdi bir örnekten
öğrenecek neler çıkıyor
ya da böyle
pekiştirmeye yönelik
üstünde durmaya yönelik
neler çıkıyor
şimdi bir
aslında bizim buradaki
list sınıfımız
ne amaçla
yazılmış
tahmin ediyorsunuz
değil mi
tabi bu profesyonel bir kod değil
ama
konuyu da çok güzel gösteriyor
ne amaçla yazılmış
yani listi doğrudan
kullanmak yerine
stud listi doğrudan
benim
stud listi sarmalayan
internal
synchronization
sağlayan
list sınıfımı
kullanan
multi-threat olarak
güvenli bir şekilde
kullanabilecek
yani ana fikir bu
detayları
boşuna
ana fikir bu
arkadaşlar
ikincisi
bakınız
mutable keyword
en güzel örneklerden biri
yani
ben mutable
keyword'ünü
kursun
en başında
anlatmıştım
ama
şimdi ona çok güzel
bir örnek
görüyorsunuz
beautiful'ı nasıl
anlatmıştım
hatırlıyor musunuz
dedim ki
bazen dedim
sınıfların
öyle veri elemanları
oluyor ki
onun
aslında
sınıf nesnesinin
problem
domenindeki
state ile
doğrudan
alakası yok
bu durumda
bunun
konstüye fonksiyonlar
tarafından da
set edilmesi
aslında
semantik açıdan
bir hata
değil
ama
sentaks açısından
hata
neden
evet
konstüye fonksiyon
demek
nesneyi değiştirmeyecek
ama nesnenin
elemanını
değiştirmeyecek
değil ki
nesnenin
o problem
domenindeki
state'ini
değiştirmeyecek
şimdi mesela
ben
buradaki
müteksi
konstüye fonksiyon
içinde ne kadar
öğretici
bakın mesela
print fonksiyonu
list sınıfının
konstüye fonksiyon
peki soru
eğer buradaki
mutable keyword'ü
olmasaydı
önce
sentaks
üzerinde
bakalım
burada
hemen
görüyorsunuz
bakın
konstüye fonksiyonların
sınıfın
non-static
veri elemanı
olan
mtx
isimli
mutex
elemanının
lag fonksiyonunu
çağırması
sentaks
hatası
olacaktı
neden
sentaks
hatası
e
çünkü
konstüye fonksiyon
veri elemanlarının
sadece
konstüye fonksiyonlarını
çağırabilir
tahmin edebileceğiniz gibi
tabii ki mutex sınıfının
lag ve
unlock fonksiyonları
konstüye fonksiyonu
değil
işte bu tür durumlarda
bu sınıflarda
sınıfın
veri elemanının
mutex olması
durumunda
çok tipik
karşımıza çıkan
bir durum
mutex'i ne yapıyoruz
sınıfın
mutable elemanı
yapıyoruz
arkadaşlar
bir örnek daha
buraya dikkat
mesela şöyle bir soru
sorulsaydı
bir mürakatta
aslında detay sorulardan
ziyade böyle sorular
daha iyi
peki
soru
şimdi burada
üye fonksiyonlar
içinde
sınıfın
veri elemanı
mtx'in
lock
unlock fonksiyonların
çağrıldığını
görüyorsunuz
soru
buradaki mutex
sınıfın
non-static
değil de
static
veri elemanı
olsaydı
yine
bu kod
internal
synchronization
sağlar mıydı
yani
soruyu
arkadaşlar
özellikle
öyle sorsalardı
şimdi bu şekilde
değil de
buraya static
koysaydı
o zaman
internal
synchronization
sağlar
diyebilir miydik
cevap
tabii ki
hayır
ne alakası var
çünkü ayrı ayrı
list nesneleri
aynı mutex
sınıfını
kullanıyor
olacak bu durumda
değil mi
tet bir mutex
sınıfı var
bütün hepsi
evet
aynı mutex
sınıfını
kullanıyor
yani o istediğimiz
bir şey
değil
yani hangi
fonksiyonda
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırırsam
çağırayım
ha yanlış anlaşılmasın
senkronizasyon
sağlanır mıydı
sorusunun
cevabı
deniz diyor ki
her sınıf için
ayrı değeri
olmazdı
a listesinin
değerini
b listesindeki
fonksiyonlar
bloklardı
bravo
ama
anımsız davranış
olur muydu
deniz akkuş
yani bu sadece
bir verim problemi
mi olurdu
yoksa
aynı zamanda
data race
de olur muydu
evet
peki
sorunun cevabını
bırakalım
ama
hiçbir zaman
tercih etmezdik
değil mi
çünkü
nesneler
birbirinden
bağımsız
ama
başka nesneler
gerekseleri
birbirini
blokluyor
olurdu
yani
tanımsız davranış
olmazdı
ama
o kodların
nesneleri
nasıl kullandığına
bağlı olarak
deadlock
oluşma ihtimali
de çok yüksek
olurdu
yani onu
kontrol etmeniz
çok zor olabilir
çünkü
aynı
mutex nesnesini
kullanır
evet
peki
arkadaşlar
o zaman
şuraya devam edelim
bakın mesela
aslında
basit bir
arkadaşlar
wrapper
değil mi
yani
diyor ki
listi doğrudan
kullanmak yerine
beni kullanırsam
benim bütün
üye fonksiyonlarım
yaptığı işlemleri
senkronize
ederek yapıyor
mesela pushback
çağrıldığı zaman
arkadaşlar
lock fonksiyonu
ve unlock fonksiyonu
yani şu pushback
kritik bölgede
aynı nesneyi
kullanacak ya
arkadaşlar
evet
bütün fonksiyonlar
aynı nesneyi
kullanıyor
yani birden fazla
thread
aynı list nesnesini
kullansa dahi
pushback'te
biri pushback yaparken
diğeri bekleyecek
diğerinin işi
bittikten sonra
ancak
diğer thread
ilerleyerek
pushback fonksiyonunu
çağırabilecek
aynı şekilde
saygı üye fonksiyonu
da
mesela bu sınıfın
bütün üye fonksiyonları
const olsaydı
o zaman
arkadaşlar
herhangi bir şekilde
bir set operasyonu
olmasaydı
yine
senkronizasyona
gerek
kalmayacaktı
evet
görüyorsunuz
hepsini tek tek
anlatmama gerek yok
ama bütün
fonksiyonlar
bütün fonksiyonların
içindeki
misti
kullanan
kritik
kodlar
arkadaşlar
gördüğünüz gibi
ne yapılmış
ha bu arada
bir şeyden daha
bahsedelim
arkadaşlar
şu
osing stream
sınıfı
c++20
standartıyla
ekledi
şimdi ben
dikkat ederseniz
örneklerin
bundan sonra da
çok göreceksiniz
örneklerin
hemen hepsinde
yani belki
%99'un da
çok kod göstereceğim ya
siyahat
nesnesine
bir şeyleri de
göstermek için
standart altında
bir şeyler yazdırmam
gerekiyor
siyahat nesnesini
doğrudan
kullanmak yerine
o siyahat'ı
sarmalayan
ama paralel olarak
çalışmasında
senkronizasyonu
sağlayan
osing stream
sınıfı
türünden
nesneleri
kullanacağım
çünkü neden
zaten konu
senkronizasyonla
ilgili
ama ekrana bir şey
yazdırırken
onu da
senkronize
etmek gerekiyor
o zaman
ana odak
noktamız
sapıyor
o yüzden
hep şöyle
düşünün
benim burada
osing stream
nesnesiyle
standart
output'a
ya da bir dosyaya
bir şeyler yazdırdığımda
orada
zaten
osing stream
sınıfı
internally
ne yapıyor
kendisi
senkronizasyonu
sağlıyor
os anesinin
hocam
üye fonksiyonların
thread safe
overloadlarının
olması
nasıl
olurdu
şimdi
bir düşünelim
thread nasıl
olabilirdi
biraz düşünmek
gerekiyor
hızlı bir şekilde
cevap vermeyeyim
bir kere
overloadlarının
olması için
imza farklılığı
olması gerekirdi
yani bence
arkadaşlar
iyi bir bakış açısı
değil bir de
bu kodların
jenerik olduğunu
düşünürseniz
yani
sağladığı
faydadan daha çok
problem getirir
gibi geliyor
ama
bazı sorularda
var ki
o aslan
böyle hemen
böyle
anında
benim cevap verip
doğru cevap
vermemide
benim üstüne
düşünmek
gerekiyor
yani ilk
kanaatim
öyle denilen
ilk kanaatim
iyi bir fikir
olmayacağı
yönünde
ama
biraz daha
üstünü
düşünmek
gerekiyor
mesela ben
olmaz öyle bir şey
falan diyorum
arkadaşlar
ondan sonra
bir
bolsan bir sınıf
yazıyor
tam da öyle
bir vektör sınıfı
al işte
necatim
sen olmaz
dedin
h gibi
sınıfım var
diyebilirim
rastur mamadop
rekürsif fonksiyonlarda
mutex kullanabilir miyiz
cevap
evet
rekürsif fonksiyonlarda
mutex
kullanabilirsiniz
ama
çok büyük ihtimalle
kullanacağınız
mutex'in
stud mutex
değil
stud recursive
mutex
olması gerekiyor
çünkü
rekürsif fonksiyonun
ne olduğuna
bağlı olarak
büyük ihtimalle
arkadaşlar
fonksiyon kendisini
çağırdığında
aynı mutex
nesnesini
kullanarak
bir kez daha
kilitlemiş
olacaksınız ki
bu durumda
tanımsız davranış
oluşur
normal mutex'i
kullandığınız zaman
yani
en iyi ihtimalle
deadlock
oluşur
evet
peki
anlaşıldı değil mi
o yüzden zaten
resul
o yüzden
rekürsif
mutex diye
ayrı bir
mutex
sınıfı var
evet evet
devam edelim
bakın
şimdi mesela
full fonksiyonunda
list sınıfı
türünden
bir referans
alıyor
arkadaşlar
buraya da
dikkat
şimdi list sınıfı
türünden
başta yaptığım
açıklamayı
hatırlıyorsanız
neyi
senkronize
etmem
gerekiyor
şimdi bazen
yeni başlayanlar
onu da anlamıyor
işte dedim ya
otomatik ömürlü
değişkeni
senkronize
etmeyeceksiniz
evet
stackteki
değişkenleri
senkronize
etmeyeceksiniz
global değişkenleri
statik sınıfların
statik veri
elemanlarını
senkronize
etmek
zorundasınız
keep üstünde
diyelim ki
siz gittiğiniz
new ifadesiyle
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesne
oluşturdunuz
ama birden fazla
thread o
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi kullanıyor
yine senkronizasyon
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
ama bakın
çok tipik bir senaryoda
buradaki
senaryo
o yüzden
kodu böyle yazdım
bir şey
dikkatinizi çekiyor mu
aslında
list
otomatik ömürlü
bir nesne
değil mi
Şengiz Han
yani buradaki
mild list
otomatik ömürlü
bir nesne
yani sakın
şöyle düşünmeyin
bu otomatik ömürlü
nesne olduğu için
hani otomatik ömürlü
nesneler
stackteydi
senkronizasyona
ihtiyacı yok
ama
bu fonksiyona
referans
semantiğiyle
geçildiğine göre
bu fonksiyonu
birden fazla
thread çalıştırdığında
o zaman
arkadaşlar
ne olacak
threadler
aynı veri üstünde
okuma yazma
işlemleri yapacak
yani otomatik
ömürlü nesne olması
senkronizasyon
gerektirmiyor
derken
fonksiyonun içindeki
otomatik ömürlü
nesnelerden
bahsediyoruz
yani artık
burada
bu referans
semantiği
kullanıldığı için
işte görüyorsunuz
bakın
3 tane
thread'i buraya
gönderdim
3 thread'te de
aynı nesne
kullanılıyor
bu arada
koda da bakın
aslında
ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
full fonksiyonu
sınıfın
pushback fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaparak
pushback fonksiyonunda
10 tane
değeri
pushback yapıyor
ama
o kolay anlaşılsın
diye şöyle yaptım
gönderdiğiniz değeri
arkadaşlar
iyi topluyor
yani 10 göndersem
10 ile 20 arası
30 göndersem
30 ile 40 arası
70 göndersem
70 ile 80 arası
necad peki
bu örnekteki
ana fikir ne
orayı anlayamadım
ya ana fikri
anlamayacak
ne var
diyormuşum
son derece basit
bu threadler
koştuktan sonra
a arkadaşlar
listenin
size'ının
30 olması
garanti altında
çünkü
senkronizasyon
yapıldı
ama bakın
hatta
isterseniz şöyle
gösterelim
bir dakika
çok güzel
aynı örnek
üstüne çalışmakta
çok faydalı
bakın şimdi
anlayacağım
görüyorsunuz
size 30
arkadaşlar
hatta debug
tamam debug
modunda kalsın
size 30
ama şimdi
pushback fonksiyonunda
arkadaşlar
lak ve
anlak çağrılarını
silelim
yani pushback
senkronize
edilmeydi
şimdi
tamamen
tanımsız
davranış
aa necati
doğru çalıştı
aa doğru çalıştığını
test etmem lazım
ve
hiçbir şekilde
bir garanti
altında
değil
evet
peki
bu demek ki
internal
synchronization
dediğimiz bir
konu daha var
sınıfın
thread safe
olması için
sınıf nesneleri
üstünde yapılan
operasyonların
thread safe
olması için
sınıf diyor ki
client'ına
sen bana güven
benim
bütün fonksiyonlarım
içinde
ben kendim
synchronize ediyorum
şimdi devam edelim
arkadaşlar
evet evet
alan diyor ki
soyut bir katman
sağlıyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi
mütex
minimal mütex
sınıfıydı ya
sadece
lak
anlak
fonksiyonu
var
demiyorum
yani
minimalizme
bir iki
öye daha dahil
arkadaşlar
yine bütün
mütex
sınıflarında
olan
ilginç bir
fonksiyon
daha var
şimdi bazen
şunu yapmamız
gerekiyor
biz
mütex ile
mütex'i
edinmeye
çalışalım
ama
edinemezsek
bloka olmayan
bu neyi sağlıyor
ya edinirsem
edinirim
yapıyı ona göre
kuruyoruz
edinmezsem de
ben yoluma
devam ederim
başka
bir iş yaparım
işte arkadaşlar
burada
tipik olarak
interfeste
diğer sınıflarda
da karşımıza
çıkacak
sınıfların
mütex sınıflarının
trial lock
isimli
bir fonksiyonu
var
mesela
bizim
mütex sınıfının
trial lock
fonksiyonunu
bir
ne diyelim
kod içinde
çalıştırsak
bu ne anlama
geliyor
mesela ben buraya
arkadaşlar
şuraya
ip deyimi
koysam
trial lock
boolean
döndürüyor
efendim
tahmin ediyorsunuz
kilidi
almışsa
kilitlemişse
kuru değer
döndürecek
evet
i tried
ve
successful
başarılı
enter
değer döndürecek
ama
kilidi
almazsa
false
değer döndürecek
ama farkına
bakın
lockta
burası
lock olsaydı
bloke olacaktı
ama şimdi
bloke olmayacak
bu da ne demek
siz örneğin
şöyle bir
deyimi yazarsanız
if
değil
mtx
trial lock
o zaman
bu şu anlama geliyor
değil mi
if'in
doğru kısmına
girerse
arkadaşlar
bir de bunun
while döngüsü
olduğunu düşünün
hatta
şöyle yazdığım
kodu
şöyle göstereyim
sembolik
çalışan bir
kod değil
anlamında
arkadaşlar
bakın
üçüncü satırda
global bir
mutex
nesnesi var
full fonksiyonu
içinde
while döngüsü
var
ama döngünün
her turunda
trial lock
fonksiyonu
çağırılıyor
şimdi şöyle de
olabilirdi
değil mi
burada
döngüye girmeden
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırırdı
efendim
kilidi edinirse
o
kilit altında
belirli işlemleri
yapardı
ama kilidi
almamışsa
bloke olurdu
öbür
thread
işini
ya da öbür
threadler daha
orada kilidi
alan belki bizimki
sona kalacak
over threadler
işini bitirene kadar
ama şimdi öyle değil
bloke olmuyor
ne oluyor
eğer
trial lock
kredi alırsa
kritik bölgeye
giriyor
almazsa
o zaman da
başka iş yapıyor
yani
biraz esprili
şekilde söylüyorum
boş duracağını
bloke olacağını
yapması gereken
bazı başka işlemler
varsa
onları
yapsın
anlamında
anlaşıldı mı
evet
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
trial lock'ın
nasıl çalıştığını
göstermek için
çok güzel bir
kod yazdım
kendi koduna da
böyle güzel
değerinden
kaçınmanız
gerekiyor
izleyin
arkadaşlar bakın
aslında
kod
trial lock'ı
çok güzel gösteriyor
şaka bir yana
şimdi bir bakalım
koda
8.
satırda
yine
global bir
speed
mutex nesnesi var
ismi
counter mutex
örneklerin
çoğunda
kitapta
benim kitaba
bakarsanız
mutex'in
hangi
shared
variable'ı
korumaya
yönelikse
ismini
böyle seçiyorum
ki en azından
bu örnek kodlar
daha yanlışılsın
diye
yani
in counter
stud mutex
counter mutex
hemen hangi
çarşımı yapıyor
demek ki
counter mutex
o counter'ın
paylaşılımı
kullanılmasında
senkronizasyon
sağlayacak
ama burada
amaç
gerçekten bu
değil
burada amaç
trial lock'ın
nasıl çalıştığını
göstermek
yani runtime'da
bunu görünce
daha etkili oluyor
arkadaşlar
dikkat ederseniz
try increase
isimli fonksiyondaki
döngü
100.000 kez
dönüyor
yani buraya
hangi
thread gelirse
gelsin
o thread
bu döngüyü
100.000 kez
dönecek
değil mi
Alian
ama bakın
burada
if
statement'ının
İngilizcesi
conditional expression'ı
try lock fonksiyonuna
yapılan çağır
yani onun
geri dönüş
değeri
bu ne demek
bizim
herhangi bir
thread'imiz
döngünün
herhangi bir
turunda
bu kilidi
edinmeye
çalışacak
kilidi edinirse
counter'ı
arttıracak
kilidi edinemezse
arkadaşlar
döngünün
bir sonraki
turuna
geçecek
ama tabii ki
try lock
true değer
verirse
kilidi edindik
otomatik olarak
unlock edinmiyor
yine bizim
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağırmamız
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakın
20. satırda
başlayan
main fonksiyonuna
bakar mısınız
şunu da
bir zahmet
açayım
evet
arkadaşlar
dikkat ederseniz
burada
kafamız karışmasın
ya bildiğimiz
cd'si var
ama
c thread
nesnelerinden
oluşan
aslında bu
neyi sağlamak
için
10 tane
thread oluşturma
pekala
burada
c thread
t1
t2
t3
t4
yapmak
yerine
böyle yazdım
burada önemli olan
main fonksiyonu
içindeki
nested block
içinde
tam
10 tane
thread
çalıştırıyorum
hepsi de
neyi koşturuyor
try increase
fonksiyonunu
koşturuyor
ama
tahmin ediyorsunuz
değil mi
arkadaşlar
try lock'lar
her birinde
başarılı olmayacak ki
tamamen
deterministik
olmayacak
olmayan
şekilde
burada
counter
belirli bir
değer alacak
bazı
try lock
çağrıları
true
döndürecek
böylece
true
döndürdüğünde
o thread
counter
arttıracak
ama
bazıları
false
döndürecek
ama
burada
sonuçta
yine bir
ne yok
bir
data race
yok
yani
bir problem
yok
evet
orada
locked ise
tabi tabi işte
tam deniz
onu söyledim
diyor ki
deniz akkoş
burada
already locked ise
skip etmiş olacağız
değil mi
evet
çünkü neden
eğer
kilitliyse
yani
başka bir thread
kilidi bırakmamışsa
lock fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş değeri
false olacak
yani kilidi edinmeyecek
ama block
eti olmayacak
yoluna devam edecek
o da döngünün
bir sonraki turnu
yani döngünün
her turunda
bir kere şansın
deniyor
ben alabilir miyim
alırsam
bu işi yapayım
alamazsam
döngününün
bir sonraki
turuna geçeyim
mesela gerçekten
koşturalım
arkadaşlar
adderli nez modunda
çalıştırayım
bazı kodları
onu şimdi açıklamayacağım
visual studio ile ilgili
bazılarını
debug modunda
çalıştırıyorum
bakın
167.971
düşünebiliyor musunuz
aslında
bu
tamamen
sen kurun
zdi zdi
100.000 çarpı
1 milyon
olması
gerekirdi
ama şimdi
edinebilirsem
ediniyorum
edinemezsem
arkadaşlar
bloke olmadan
yoluma
devam ediyorum
diyor
tekrar söylüyorum
bu kod tamamen
yani aklınıza şöyle bir soru gelebilir
niye böyle bir şey yapayım ki
yapmam
tabi bu örnek
tamamen
trylock'ın
aslında
bloke olmadan
çalıştığını
göstermeye yönelik
ama
trylock gibi bir fonksiyonun
benzer fonksiyonlar da var
mesela time mutex olsaydı
bir de bunun
nasıl
versiyonları var
diyelim
arkadaşlar mutex sınıfında yok
ama time mutex sınıfında var
trylock var
bir de
time mutex sınıfında
mesela
trylock for
trylock until
fonksiyonları da var
eğer bu
time mutex
sınıfı olsaydı
ki
aradan sonra
ona da
geçeriz
time mutex olsaydı
trylock yerine örneğin
trylock for
fonksiyonunu çağırsaydım
basta yapalım da ya
yani ara vermeden
şimdi bu kod anlaşıldı
değil mi
use days
anlaşıldı
bakın bakın
şimdi ben
şöyle bir şey yapsam
sıra
krono başlık dosyasını
dahil edeyim
takip etmeye çalışın
edebildiğiniz kadar
using
namespace
stut
literals
yani şu
literal operatörleri
kullanabilmek için
yazdım
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
bu sınıfın
trylock for
diye bir fonksiyonu yok
çünkü bu
adi mütex
burada adi
şerefsiz anlamında
değil biliyorsunuz
yani normal
artık herkes
adiyi
kötü anlamıyla alıyor
şey
adi demek
normal demek
aslında
yani
ekstra bir özelliği
olmayan
şerefsiz anlamında
değil
bakın
trylock for
fonksiyonu yok
mesela böyle bir şey
yazsam
arkadaşlar ne kadar
süreyle edinmeye
çalışsın
mesela
20 milisaniye
öyle bir şey yok
ama
bu
stut
mütex
olmasaydı
stut
time
mütex
olsaydı
görüyorsunuz
artık
sentaksa
tansiyon
işte bakın
interfejsten
interfejleri
farklı
mütex
sınıfları
var derken
kast edilen bu
mesela
gerçekten
böyle bir ihtiyaç
olsaydı
o zaman
zaten
mütex'i kullanamam ki
mütex bana bu
şansı vermiyor
ama bu ihtiyacın
olmadığı noktada da
mesela burada
çok güzel bir örnek
bakın burada
ben yine
trylock for gibi
bir fonksiyonu
çağırmak yerine
burada
trylock fonksiyonu
çağırsaydım
o zaman
boş yere
ekstra
maliyet ödemiş
olurdum
yani
o ne kadar
onu tabi
profilingle
bakmak lazım
ama sonuçta
mutlaka bir ilave
maliyeti var
yani gerekmiyorsa
o zaman
daha
geniş bir
interfejse sahip
mütex sınıfını
kullanmayın
demeye getiriyorum
evet
ama biz
time mütex
yine eski haline getireyim
trylock
for
20 milisaniye
bu ne demek
boyunca
edinecek
ama yine
bloke olmayacak
anlaşıldı değil mi
yani 20 milisaniye
boyunca
edinmeye çalışacak
20 milisaniyede
edinemezse
bloke
olmayacak
yine burada
trylock for
trylock until
bunların
geri dönüş değeri
yine
bu
bu arada
şu çifti
göstermek için de
çok güzel bir örnek
arkadaşlar
isminde böyle
sonunda for
geçenler
tahmin ediyorsunuz
hep duration
istiyor
bunlar aslında
sınıfların
member
template
fonksiyonları
içinde duration
geçenler
özür dilerim
içinde sonunda
for olanlar
duration istiyor
ama
bir de
sonunda
until olanlar
var
aradaki
tek fark ne
until olanlar ise
time point
istiyor
yani şu
time point'te
gelene kadar
mesela
aradaki farka
bakın
en azından
bunu göreyim
böyle ara verelim
arkadaşlar
vermiyorum
valla şimdi
çok da iddialı
konuşmamak
gerekiyor
ben
çıkarımınızı
anladım
ama
hemen evet ya da
hayır demiyorum
çünkü kodun ne
olduğuna bağlı
çünkü
bu kaç kez
olmuş
mesela
bir milyon
on kez
20 milisaniye
beklediğinde
her defasında
almış
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
20 milisaniye
peki biraz azaltalım
evet ama
bir dakika
Deniz diyor ki
5 kere denedim
bence 5 denemeye
böyle yapmak farklı
şuraya giderek
azaltmak farklı
mesela
1 milisaniye
1 milisaniye ne
saniyenin
binde biri
bu arada
benim makinem de
eski
arkadaşlar
fakirlikten
alamadım
diyor
bakın
şimdi
35 kere
alamamış
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi bakın
iyice azaltalım
milisaniyeden sonra
ne geliyor
necati
mikrosaniye
o zaman
mesela
mikrosaniye
yani deminki
sürenin
yarısı kadar
sürede
almaya çalışıyor
şimdi daha da
azalacak
evet
e
mikrosaniye
mikro
bin
e
necati uzatma
yap de şunu
5 mikrosaniye
tamam
bakın
5 mikrosaniyede
düştü
hadi
son örnek
1 mikrosaniye
yapalım
deniz akkuş
diyor ki
1 mikrosaniye
ile
bin
kez
işte
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
aradaki farkı
resul bu arada
şöyle diyor
adi sözü
bizde
yalnızca
sıradan
sade
demek
resul
türkçede de
öyle
yani
türkçede de
aslında adi zaten
türkçe kökenli bir sözcük değil
bizde de öyle de
ama daha çok o
ne denir ona
pejoratif deniyor
değil mi
pejoratif olarak kullanıyor
eskiden türkçeyi yeni öğrendiğimde
filmlerde
sen ne adi adamsın
kötü anlamda
diyorlardı
ilk başta
sen ne sade adamsın
diye almıyorum
bu da çok güzel
onu ben
örnek olarak
vereyim
aziz türkçesiyle ilgili
konuştuğumda
evet
peki
en son
şunu göstermiştim
1 mikrosaniye
arkadaşlar
ooo
564 bin
ama tabi şimdi
bu makinenin
işte
bir silah falan da
ilgili değil mi
yani
1 mikrosaniyede
990 bin küsur
diyor
evet
ona ben de katılıyorum
biraz şimdi
konu dışına çıkıyoruz ama
adam sözcüğü de
o da bakın
tamamen bir yanlış anlama
yani biraz böyle
entelektüel hastalığı
şimdi
bilim insanı falan
diye şeyler çıkarttılar ya
İngilizceden özenip
oradaki adamın
erkekle bir alakası yok
oradaki adam
Adem anlamında
yani o da insan demek
bilim adamı demek zaten
bilim erkeği demek değil ki
bilim insanı demek zaten
dolayısıyla bilim adamı yerine
tabi sadece bilim için değil
iş adamı
iş insanı
bilim adamı
bilim insanı
ben de hatta bazen
espri yapıyorum
derslerde diyorum
programcı insanı
ya çok da kötü duruyor
diye bir şey olur mu
meclis
insanı
falan diye
yani
değil
yani bizdeki adam
Resul
bizdeki adamın
asıl doğru kullanımı
Adem anlamında
yani Adem de
burada insan
anlamında
cinsiyetten
ari
erkek de olsa
Adem
Ademoğlu deniyor ya
Ademoğlu deyince
mesela erkek mi
oluyor değil
ben bu tür şeylere
entelektüel hastalığı
diyorum
yani gereksiz yere
bu ekşi sözlük
falan tarzı
şeylerden ediyorlar
gereksiz yere
duyar kasmak
böyle bir şey de çıktı
şimdi Türkçe'ye
sizde var mı
Azeri Türkçesinde
duyar kasmak
bu yoktur kesin
bir ara veriyorum
saat 21.12
21.30'da
devam edeceğiz
kayıttan izleyenler
bu
çatteki yazışmaları
görmediği için
az önce bir arkadaşım
bir şey sordu
onunla
yazıştık
ben hızlı bir şekilde
okuyayım
çünkü
önemli olabilir
soru
şöyle diyor
arkadaşım
hocam detayını
ben de çok
bilmiyorum ama
Xcode ve
Clank'te
C++20 olmasına rağmen
J-Thread
tanımı yok
böyle bir şeye
denk gelmiş miydiniz
ben de cevap olarak
şöyle yazdım
şimdi
bir derleyicinin
standardı
desteklemesi
şöyle değil
ya tamamen
destekliyor
ya hiç
desteklemiyor
şeklinde değil
yani
standardın
birili öğelerini
desteklemiyor
olabilir
zaman içinde
yavaş yavaş
onları da
ekliyorlar
mesela
benim kullandığım
derleyici
yani benim kursda
kullandığım
derleyici
Microsoft
derleyicisi
C++23'deki
bazı öğeleri
destekliyor
hatta
C++26'daki
bazı öğeleri
bile desteklerken
neyi desteklemiyor
C++20'nin
bazı özelliklerini
desteklemeyebiliyor
ve ben de
şunu önerdim
arkadaşıma
arkadaşlar
göstereyim
bir dakika
cppreference.com'da
bunu takip eden
zaten bir sayfa
var
mümkün olduğu
kadar
güncel
tutuyorlar
şimdi
görüyorsunuz
bakın
compiler
support
for C++20
burada
bütün
özellikleri
almış
ve
şu derleyiciler
için
GCC
Clank
Microsoft
Apple
Intel
hepsini okumuyorum
bunlar için
hangilerini
destekleyip
desteklemediğini
sürüm numarasıyla
beraber vermiş
yani
ama şöyle bir ihtimal de var
en son onu da ekledim
bazı derleyicilerde de
şöyle olabiliyor
değerli arkadaşlar
bazı özellikleri
destekliyor
ama
onun için
İngilizcesiyle
conditional
compiling
gerekebiliyor
yani
koşullu derneğime
mesela diyelim ki
bir makroyu
define etmeniz
tanımlamanız
gerekiyor olabilir
artık derleyiciden
derleyici
durumlar
biraz
farklı olabiliyor
evet
o zaman örneklere
devam edelim
arkadaşlar
bir öyle bir hızla
çok da
hızlı gitmek istemiyorum
çok da yavaş gitmek
istemiyorum
arkadaşlar
mesela bakın
buradaki örneğe
bu örnekte
aslında
Arayan Bey'in
sorusunun
bir yerde
yine cevabı
olacak
nitelikte
koda bakalım
şimdi
9. satırda
şöyle göstergemi
de açayım
9. satırda
Global
Studmyotex
nesnesi var
Bu ve bar
isimli
iki fonksiyon
var
bir thread
foo'yu
koşturuyor
yani
word load
olarak
foo'yu
alıyor
diğer thread
barı
alıyor
yani
aynı zamanda
3 tane
thread
birden çalışıyor
main thread
ve 2 tane
child thread
efendim
görüyorsunuz
foo içinde
foo is
triangle
locked
the mutex
yazısı
çıkacak
burada
özellikle
bar fonksiyonunda
milisaniye
bloke edildiğini
görüyorsunuz
ki
bunun nedeni
açık
önce
foo'yu
foo'nun
çalıştığını
göstermek
için
bu durumda
ekranda
şu yazı
çıkacak
değil mi
çok çok
büyük bir
süpriz
olmazsa
foo is
trying to lock
the mutex
sonra mutex
lock edecek
kilitleyecek
bu arada
tabi barı çalıştıran
arkadaşlar
aynı
mutex söz konusu
olduğu için
şurada
try lock
fonksiyonuna
bakın
orada
mutex'in
kilitli
olması
durumunda
arkadaşlar
false
değer olacak
ve
false
değer olursa
vile'nin
vile döngüsünün
gövdesine
girecek ve
sürekli
bu yazı
çıkacak
ta ki
ne zamana
kadar
foo fonksiyonu
aynı mutex'i
örnek çok güzel
aslında
unlock edince
bu sefer
döngünün
falanca turunda
onu bilemeyiz
tabi
döngünün
falanca turunda
kaçıncı turunda
bilemiyorum
bu döngüden
çıkacak
mutex'i
aldığı için
ve
efendim işte
bar has locked
the mutex
yazısı
çıkacak
ve
yine
30.
satırdaki
çareyle
mutex'i
unlock
gelecek
şimdi
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
bakın
burada
800 milisaniye
bekledim
görüyor musunuz
who is trying
to lock the mutex
bu çıktı
who has locked
the mutex
gerçekten kilitledi
şimdi bakın
burada 800
milisaniye
bekliyor
tabi
800 milisaniye
beklerken
bu da
arkadaşlar
her 100
milisaniyede
bir
bir kere
şansını deniyor
ilk 100
milisaniyede
kilidi alamadı
ikinci de
alamadı
üçüncü de
dördüncü de
alamadı
fakat
nihayetinde
arkadaşlar
aldı
aldığı
zamanda
ama
aldığı
zamanda
görüyorsunuz
bak çok güzel
gösteriyor
şu yazı
çıktı
who is
unlocking
the mutex
bu serbest
bırakınca
bizimki
artık
döngüden
mutex'i
alarak
arkadaşlar
döngüden
çıktı
değil mi
süper
arkadaşlar
şimdi yavaş yavaş
şu
deadlock
konusuna da
gelelim
ya da
deadlock'a mı gelelim
diğer mutex
sınıflarına mı
gelelim
önce biraz
deadlock'tan
bahsedelim
şimdi
deadlock
aslında şu demek
birçok nedenden
olabilir ama tipik olarak
en tipik nedeni
deadlock'ların en tipik
nedeni
birden fazla
mutex'in
kilitlenmesi
en tipik nedenlerden biri
fakat farklı
threadlerin
mutex'leri
farklı sırada
kilitlemesi
şimdi
onu gösteren
gayet de güzel
bir örnek
ama oraya daha
geçmeyelim
ondan önce daha
anlatacağım bir sürü
şey var
şimdi kafanızı
karıştırmak
istemiyorum
deadlock'a ayrı bir
başlık altında
değinirim ve
komple
onun üstünden
gidelim
şimdi önce
örneğimizin doğrudan
deadlock'la
asla alakası yok
şu
rapper sınıflar
neden gerekiyor
onu gösteren
bir örnek
hazırladım
izleyin şimdi
arkadaşlar bakın
tamamen bahsettiğim
senaryo
şimdi kodu
anlamaya çalışalım
yavaş yavaş
gidelim ki
bir
buradaki
my terminate
fonksiyonu
terminate'in
çalıştığını
göstermek için
daha önce
anlatmıştım
böylece
set terminate'le
arkadaşlar
my terminate'i
kayıt altına
aldım
terminate fonksiyonu
abort'u çağırmak
yerine
my terminate'i
çağırılacak
böylece
ben de
standart output'ta
my terminate
cold yazısını
gördüğümde
terminate fonksiyonunun
çağırıldığını
anlayacağım
şimdi
bu
full fonksiyonu
iki farklı
thread tarafından
çalıştırılıyor
görüyorsunuz
burada
yalnız
dry blue
içinde
buraya dikkat
kilit altında
dry blue
onda 13.
13.
satırda
lock fonksiyonu
çağırılıyor
17.
satırda
unlock fonksiyonu
çağırılıyor
fakat
exception göndermeye
bir örnek olsun diye
fonksiyona gönderilen
argüman
eğer
shift sayıysa
yani x mod 2
eşit eşit
sıfırsa
runtime
error gönderiyor
yani
stot runtime
türünden bir
exception
gönderiyor
error
info
yazısı
argüman olarak
geçiyor
fakat şimdi ne olacak
buradaki tema ne
eğer ben
burada
exception
throw edilirse
programın akışı
exception
handler'a
gelecek
exception
yakalandı
kodu çıkacak
dolayısıyla
exception
yakalanacak
ama
unlock
fonksiyonu
çağırılmayacak
buradaki
200 milisaniye
bekletme
kodunu
neden
eklediğimi
tahmin edebiliyorsunuz
değil mi
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi
burayı
ilk olarak
4 ile
çağırdığımda
burada
200 milisaniye
beklediği zaman
arkadaşlar
hatta
gösterelim
bu arada
bakın
bir 4
bir 3
değeriyle
çağırıyorum
tabi
deterministik
olmadığını
biliyoruz
şimdi
gördünüz mü
bakın
exception
code
info
error
ne oldu
birer
thread
orada
takıldı
yani
şu anda
programın
akışı
arkadaşlar
şeye
geldiğinde
işte hangisi ise
join'e geldiğinde
bitmiyor
çünkü
şuradaki
kilit
halen
edinemiyor
çünkü
diğeri
exception
göndererek
kilidi
unlock etmedi
o
unlock etmediği için
bizimki de
kilidi alamıyor
ama alma şansı da
kalmadı artık
öyle değil mi
çünkü
programın
akışının
bir daha
oraya gelme
ihtimali
yok
arkadaşlar
bu arada
tabi şunu da
söyleyelim
buradaki
exception
gönderilmesi
derleyiciye
bağlı
yani böyle bir durumda
exception göndermek
zorunda da
değil
o
kesinlikle
derleyiciye
bağlı
peki
şimdi
yani exception
göndermek zorunda
değil derken
yanlış anlaşılmasın
hani thread bloke
olduğunda
ne olacak
sorusunun cevabı
da orada
derleyicinin
nasıl bir
poder et
yani bazı durumlarda
deadlock
senaryosunu
derleyici
gördüğü zaman
şey kodu da
kendi
biraz
inisiyatifiyle
exception gönderme
kodu da
ekleyebiliyor
orası da
derleyiciye bağlı
bir durum da var
onu demek istiyorum
şimdi
neyse
konumuza
gelelim
şimdi
bakınız
eğer ben burada
mutex'i
sarmalayan
bir sınıf
kullansaydım
henüz
görmedik ama
kullanalım
efendim
mesela
lock card
sınıfını
kullanayım
izleyin
stut
lock card
bir template
template argümanı
mutex'in türü
yani normalde
şöyle yazmam
lazım
lock card'ın
stut
mutex
açılımı
efendim
diyelim ki
ismi
lock
lock olmasın
ismi
değeriye karışmasın
guard olsun
şimdilik
ve
argüman olarak
mutex nesnesini
veriyorum
şimdi ne oluyor
burada
argüman olarak
mutex nesnesini
alıyor
ve mutex'in
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
arkadaşlar
ama
bu
nesne
destroy
olduğunda
yani
lock card türünden
olan guard nesnesi
için
destructor
çağırıldığında
ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
destructor
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
mutex'in
dolayısıyla
burada
exception
göndermese
zaten
blok içinde
oluşturulan
yerel bir nesne
olduğu için
scope'un sonuna
geldiğinde
destructor'ı
çağırılacak
destructor
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
eğer
exception
gönderilirse
de
19.
satırdaki
patch blue ile
exception
yakalandığı
için
bu seferde
stack
unwinding
sürecinde
yine
o stack
unwinding
hatırlayın
otomatik
ömürlü
nesneler
her
stack
frame'den
çıkıldığında
destructor'ları
çağırılıyordu
şimdi durum
değişti
yani şimdi
orada takılma
ihtimali
arkadaşlar
gördüğünüz gibi
kalmadı
evet
peki
arkadaşlar
yalnız bakın
burada
önemli bir noktaya
daha değineceğim
ilginç
şimdi kilitleme
mekanizmasını
yanlış anlamamakta
gerekiyor
birkaç tane
kod gösterelim
şimdi bir
maliyet faktörü
var
bir de
bazı durumlarda
gerçekten
lock fonksiyonunu
nerede
çağırdığınızda
da ilgili
mesela şu koda
bakın
aslında bir konuyu
çok güzel gösteriyor
önce bir kodu
anlamaya çalışalım
bir anda
runtime'i görmeyeceğiz
çünkü
sadece kod üstünde
fonksiyonun
tanımı üstünde
konuşacağız
arkadaşlar
A sınıfı
türünden
bir pointer var
bu
null pointer
değerinde
statik ömürlü
yani
hayata geldiğinde
main fonksiyonu
çağrılmadan
hayata gelecek
main fonksiyonu
çağrılmadan
hayata geldiğinde
null PTR
değeriyle
hayata gelecek
dokuzuncu satırda
da bir
mutex nesnesi var
şimdi full fonksiyonuna
bakın
şimdi full fonksiyonu
burada
sadece
bir tane
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
yani her
thread'in
dinamik ömürlü
nesnesini
kontrol etmek için
buraya dikkat edin
daha doğrusu
özür dilerim
bir tane
dinamik ömürlü
nesne
oluşturulması için
if deyiminde
GBA'nın
değeri
null pointer ise
if'in
doğru kısmına
girecek
if'in doğru kısmına
girdiğinde
arkadaşlar
dinamik ömürlü
A nesnesini
oluşturacak
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
ve burada
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
şimdi burada
thread safety
var mı?
var
ama
gereksiz de bir
mariyet var
değil mi?
çünkü
buraya her
girdiğinde
artık
bir kere
biz nesneyi
kullanmak istediğimiz
zaman
bu fonksiyonu
her çağırdığımızda
nesne
yaratılsa da
yaratılmasa da
burada
lock fonksiyonu
çağırılmış olacak
burayı anladık mı?
yani burada
thread safety
açısından
herhangi bir problem
var mı?
bir data race
yok
ama problemle
gereksiz yere
her defasında
lock fonksiyonunun
çağırılması
zaten İngilizce
yorum satırıda
koymuşuz
thread safe
but costi
maliyeti var
şimdi kodu biraz
değiştiriyorum
izleyin
testte bir
soru soruyorum
arkadaşlar
aynı
kod gibi
görünüyor
ve bakın
sizce bu
thread safe mi
değil mi?
yani thread safe mi
derken
bir tane
A nesnesinin
yaratılacağı
oluşturulacağı
ikinci A nesnesinin
oluşturulamayacağı
garantisi var mı?
cevap
garanti yok
bravo hala
neden?
arkadaşlar
çünkü
burada
örneğin
bir thread
gpa'yı
arkadaşlar
set ettin
yani null
ikisi birden
buraya gelebilir
ikisinde de
null pointer olabilir
değil mi?
ama içeri girdiğinde
bekleyecek
dolayısıyla
diğeri
kilidi serbest
bıraktığında
o yine
ikinci bir
A nesnesi
oluşturacak
burayı anladık mı?
yani
bu
thread safe
değil
isterseniz deneyin
full fonksiyonu içinde
full fonksiyonunu
farklı iki
thread'den
çalıştırın
ama bakın
şimdi şöyle bir
idiomatik yapı var
buna
Alihan diyor ki
iki thread'de de
null iken
girebilir
evet kesinlikle
zaten problem o
ama bakın
şimdi
idiomatik bir yapı var
double checked
locking
pattern'da
deniyor
şimdi ona
bakalım
bu kod hakkında
yorum yapalım
arkadaşlar
burada dikkat
ederseniz
şimdi
birinci
if'te
logic
değil operatörü
bu kontrolü
yapıyor ama
bakın bu kontrolü
kilit altında
yapmıyor
takip edebiliyor musunuz
yani 15. satırdaki
gpa'nın değeri
null pointer mı
kontrolünü
kilit altında
yapmıyor
dolayısıyla
buraya geldiğinde
gpa'nın değeri
dikkat
null pointer
değilse zaten
if'in içine
hiç girmeyecek
hiç girmeyeceği için
lock
unlock
fonksiyonları
çağrılmayacak
yani
mutex'e edinmeye
çalışmayacak
burayı anladık mı
tekrar anlatayım mı
eğer bir
thread full
fonksiyonunun
içine girdiğinde
zaten
gpa'nın
değerini
arkadaşlar
null pointer
olarak
okumazsa
yani
not null ise
o zaman
zaten
if'in doğru
kısmına
girmeyecek
if'in doğru
kısmına
girmemesi demek
lock
fonksiyonu
çağırılmayacak
yani boş yere
kilitleme
maliyetine
girmiş
olmayacağız
burayı anladık mı
evet
ama diyelim ki
içine girdi
ama içine girerse de
şöyle bir problem var
değil mi
ee
az önceki
bir önceki örnekte
olduğu gibi
iki thread
birden buraya
girmiş olur
ama şimdi
kilitlemeyi yapıyor
artık burada
kilitlediğine göre
burası kilit altında
çalıştığına göre
arkadaşlar
gpa'nın
değeri
halen
null pointer
ise
bu sefer
nesneyi
oluşturuyor
espriyi anladınız mı
bu çok güzel
bir paten
yani burada
diyeceksiniz ki
arada ne fark var
aradaki fark
bir önceki örnekten
ilk verdiğimiz örnekte
buraya
her geldiğinde
kilitliyordu
ama şimdi
buraya gelen
thread
her defasında
bu kilidi
çalıştırmayacak
geliş zamanının
ne olduğuna
bağlı olarak
ne zaman
denk geldiğine
bağlı olarak
birçok durumda
mesela ne olacak
gpa
null pointer
olmadığı için
zaten
if'in
doğru kısmına
girmeyecek
ama if'in
doğru kısmına
girerse
bu sefer
ne var
ne riski var
null pointer
ken
iki thread
birden
buraya girmiş
olabilir
ama iki thread
buraya girmiş
olsa dahi
burada artık
kilidi edindiğimize
göre
arkadaşlar
tekrar baktığımda
artık buraya
ikinci bir thread'in
girme şansı yok
gpa
null pointer
demek ki
bizden önce
buraya giren
eş zamanlı olarak
diyebileceğimiz
şekilde giren
thread
zaten o
nesneyi
oluşturmuş
ben onun
garantisini
elde ediyorum
içteki
if
değimiyle
çok güzel
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
gelelim
tipik deadlock
senaryosuna
örnek
biraz zamanımızı
alacak
ama çok güzel
bir örnek
yani en tipik
deadlock
senaryosu
şimdi
deadlock'ın
merak etmeyin
açıklayacağım
biraz fazla
kod var
deadlock'ın
en tipik
görüntüsü şu
ya da en tipik
oluşum
nedeni şu
arkadaşlar
biri
birini bekliyor
diğeri de
diğerini
bekliyor
yani
birinin
ilerlemesi
için
diğerinin
ilerlemesi
gerekiyor
kilidi serbest
bırakması
gerekiyor
aynı durum
over thread
için de
geçerli
bu durumda
ikisi de
farklı
mutex
nesnelerinin
unlock
edilmesini
bekliyor
necati
denizin
tuttuğu
mutex'in
unlock
edilmesini
bekliyor
denizde
necati'nin
tuttuğu
mutex'in
unlock
edilmesini
bekliyor
bu durumda
deadlock
oluşuyor
yani bu
tabi tekrar tekrar
söylüyorum
deadlock
oluşumunda
tek
senaryo
şüphesiz
değil
başka örnekler
de gösteririm
ilerleyen
zamanda
ama
en tipik
senaryo bu
şimdi bunu da
neden söylüyorum
buradaki
deadlock
böyle deadlock
oluşumlarında
tipik olarak
a
arkadaşlar
nedenle
birden fazla
kilidin
kullanılması
bir kilit
edinmişken
ikinci bir kilitin
edinilmesi
çabası
ama
bir kilit
edinmişken
neyi de
düşünmeliyiz
benim
edindiğim
kilidi
bekleyen
yani onun
unlock edilmesini
bekleyen
başka
threadler
olabilir mi
olabilirse
ikinciyi
asla
edinmemeniz
gerekiyor
bu da şu
demek
mesela
iki ayrı
thread
ne diyelim
iki ayrı
mutex
kullanıyorsa
ikisi de
iki mutex
kullanıyorsa
bunların
mutex
edinme
sıralarının
aynı olması
gerekiyor
şimdi buraya
bakın açıklama
yazdım
bir beraber
okuyalım
aşağıdaki
koda
koda bakacağız
deadlock
oluşuyor
her iki
thread de
bloke ediliyor
bloke oluyor
fu'yu yürüten
thread'in
fu bu
devam edebilmesi
için
barı yürüten
thread'in
bmtx'i
serbest
bırakması
gerekiyor
şimdi göreceğiz
barı yürüten
thread'in
devam edebilmesi
için de
fu'yu yürüten
thread'in
amtx'i
serbest
bırakması
gerekiyor
eğer
mutexler
her iki
thread tarafından
da aynı
sırada
edinilseydi
bir sorun
oluşmayacaktı
işte o
sorun nasıl
oluşmayacak
o sorunun
oluşmamasını
sağlayan
birden fazla
araç var
ilerleyen saatlerde
göreceğiz
ama önce
şimdi
fu'ya
bakalım
arkadaşlar
fu
bu arada
thread'in
id'sini de
yazdırıyorum ki
hangi thread'in
hangi mutex'i
kilitlemeye
çalıştığını
runtime'da
görelim
bu arada
tabi ki
siya hatun da
ayrıca
senkronize
edilmesi
gerekiyor
o yüzden
arkadaşlar
osing stream
sınıfını
kullandım
osing stream'e
bakmayın
onu bir ara
açıklarım
şimdi
fu'da
ilk önce
fu
yubi thread
koşturduğunda
şu yazı
çıkacak
buraya kadar
okey
arkadaşlar
burada
amtx
isimli
mutex'i
kilitleyecek
buraya dikkat
amtx isimli
mutex'i
kilitleyecek
kilitler kilitlemez
standart
outputta
şu yazı
çıkacak
ama ondan
sonra
deadlock
senaryosunu
oluşturmak
için
100 milisaniye
uyuttum
500 milisaniye
bekledi
bekledikten sonra
bu sefer
bmtx'i
edinmeye
çalışacak
bakın halen
amtx'i
anlak etmedi
değil mi
burası çok önemli
bakın
en tipik senaryo
amtx'i
anlak etmeden
yani
bir mutex'i
tutarken
ikinci bir mutex'i
daha
ediniyor
ama tahmin
ediyorsunuz
değil mi
ikinci
mutex'i
edindiği
zaman
edinmeye
çalıştığı
zaman
bu edinmeye
çalıştığı
mutex'i de
arkadaşlar
edinmiş biri
olabilir
değil mi
şimdi
burada da
şöyle bir yazı
çıkarttım
has
locked
be
mutex
eğer burada
da
lock etmeyi
başarırsa
zaten
runtime'da
ayna gibi
göreceksiniz
ne diyecek
efendim
bu
id
ayna
b mutex'ini
de
kitleyecek
ondan sonra
a'yı
anlak ediyor
anlak
ettiğini gösteren
yazı
yazdırıyor
sonra da
b'yi
anlak ediyor
işte bakın
tahmin ediyorsunuz
değil mi
nasıl bir senaryo
kurduğumu
şimdi
diğerinin
ilerlemesi için
bu kodun
çalışması
gerekecek
bunun ilerlemesi
için de
hemen
diğerine
bakalım
arkadaşlar
bu da
önce
b'yi
kitliyor
yani
düşünün
b'yi
kitlediğine göre
şu anda
şunun
ilerleyebilmesi
için
bar fonksiyonunu
çalıştıran
thread'in
b
mtx'i
b mutex'ini
unlock etmesi
gerekiyor
runtime'da
çok güzel
göreceksiniz
sonra işte
b'yi kitlediğini
söylüyor
burada da bu
500 milisaniye
bekliyor
şimdi
mutex
oluşacak
deadlock
neden
arkadaşlar
bu
a mutex'i
bekliyor
öbürü de
b mutex'i
bekliyor
ama
a mutex'ini
lock etmesi
için
bunun
buraya gelmesi
lazım
programın
akışının
diğeri
için de
arkadaşlar
bunun da
diğerine
bakalım
diğerinin de
b mutex'i
edinebilmesi
için
programın
akışının
buraya gelmesi
gerekiyor
burada
ikisi
birden
ne olacak
blok olacak
ilerleyemiyor
biri
bir mutex'i
bekliyor
ama
diğeri de
diğer mutex'i
bekliyor
ama
birbirinin
unlock etmesi
gerekiyor
o da
ilerleyemediği için
unlock'a gelmiyor
programın
akışı
bu
deadlock
senaryoları
başta zihinde
canlandırmak için
biraz daha
karmaşık
olabilir
bakın ama
şimdi
çok güzel
gördük
izleyin
şimdi
treplerden bir
tanesinin
id'si 24312
imiş
işte şu
beraber şöyle
bakalım
bence örnek
çok güzel
evet
is trying to
lock a mutex
buraya geldi
şimdi
a'yı
kitledi
takip edebiliyorsunuz
değil mi
evet
şimdi öbür
thread
b'yi
kitlemeye
çalıştı
b'yi
kitledi
bizim
thread'imiz
şu programın
akışı
şuraya
geldi
bakın
arkadaşlar
is trying
to lock
a mutex
yani
şuraya
geldi
burada
takıldı
çünkü
diğer thread
halen bunu
serbest
bırakmadı
diğeri de
b'yi
kitlemeye
çalışıyor
peki
soru
mesela
burada
deadlock
senaryosunun
ortadan
kalkması
ya da
oluşmasının
nedenine
ortadan
kalkması
içinde
olması
gerekiyor
son derece
basit
arkadaşlar
burada
deadlock'ın
oluşmasının
nedeni
iki thread'in
iki mutex'i
farklı sırada
kilitlemesi
yani
şöyle olsaydı
bakınız
isterseniz
deneyelim
bu da
a
önce
kitlesin
b'yi
sonra
kitlesin
arkadaşlar
şimdi
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
yani
sırayı
aynı yaptım
şu
ekseyi
kapatalım
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
evet
bakın
gördünüz değil mi
sıra
aynı olduğu zaman
ilerlemedi
diğeri
yoluna
devam
ettiği zaman
o ne zaman
diğerinin
beklediği
mutex'i
unlock
ederse
öbürü
yoluna
devam
edecek
bunun için
sıranın
aynı
olması
gerekiyor
alian
bozkır
diyor ki unlock
etme sıraları
değil lock
önemli değil mi
evet
şimdi
doğrusu isterseniz
burada
aslında
bunu
istediğim
sırada
lock
etmeme
rağmen
algoritmik
bir şekilde
bunu
halleden
aslında bir
fonksiyon var
ona da
ilerleyen
dakikalarda
geleceğiz
bu fonksiyonun
ismi
lock
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
isimlendirme
de bir dert
şimdi ismi
lock olan
bir fonksiyon var
bu global
bir fonksiyon
bir de
mutex'lerin
lock isimli
fonksiyonu var
şimdi ikisini
birbiriyle
karıştırmayalım
mesela
şöyle olsaydı
izleyin
standart
lock
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
bu
arkadaşlar
görün
variadik
bir fonksiyon
buna
n tane
mutex
verebiliyorsunuz
mesela
neydi
isimleri
amtx
gerçi onun için
da ayrı örnek
hazırladım
şimdi burayı
bozmak istemiyorum
ama
virgül
bmtx
şimdi
diğeri
artık
sırasının
hiçbir önemi
yok
orada
arka planda
lock'ın
kullandığı
algoritma
arkadaşlar
yalnız
tabi
şöyle
ikinci kez
şunu
kaldırıyorum
tamam
sadece
unlock'lar
kalsın
yine
burada
bmtx
lock'ı
kaldırdım
ve yine
aynı kodu
buraya yazayım
yani
bu işi
iki
kilidi
de
kilitmeme
işini
lock
fonksiyonuna
verirseniz
lock
fonksiyonuna
geçtiğiniz
argümanların
sırasının
ne olduğundan
bağımsız olarak
lock
fonksiyonunun
kullandığı
algoritma
bunu hallediyor
evet
variadik fonksiyon
ama
şimdi bir şey
söyleyeyim
şimdi
o kadar çok
alt başlık
var ki
birbirine de
yavaş yavaş
girmeye başlıyor
hangisini önce
anlatalım
hangisini sonra
arada böyle
başka konulara
gönderme
yapmak zorundayım
önce bir bitirelim
örneği
mesela
bmutex
amutex
önce
Alihan Bey'in
sorusuna cevap
verelim
variadik mi
variadik
yani variadik
olması şu
anlamda
şimdi ben
lock fonksiyonuna
burada iki tane
mutex olmasaydı
beş tane
mutex olsaydı
ve ben
bütün
tradelerde
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
beş mutex'i de
herhangi bir sırada
argüman olarak
geçseydim
yine deadlock
oluşmama garantisi
olacak mıydı
evet
yalnız bir şeye
dikkat edin
tabii ki
arkadaşlar
burada
yine
kilitlediğim
bütün mutex'leri
unlock etmek
zorundayım
ama
ayrı ayrı
ayrı
neyi
çağırmıyorsunuz
lock fonksiyonunu
her bir mutex için
ayrı çağırmıyorsunuz
yani
bu mutex'leri
kilitlemeyi
lock fonksiyonu
kendisi yapıyor
işte
burada
c++
17'ye kadar
böyle durumlarda
çözümlerden biri
belki
hani sırayı
istediğim gibi
oluşturayım
deadlock olmasın
bu
lock fonksiyonuydu
fakat sonra
scope lock diye
bir
guard sınıfı
eklediler
dersin en başına
geri döndü
hani
bir mutex sınıflarının
listesini yaptım
ondan sonra da
guard sınıflarının
listesini yaptım
guard sınıfları
şunlardı
isimler de birbirine
çok yakın
lock guard
onu az önce
gördük
sadece bir örnek
yaptık
ama
başka neler var
unique lock
o
kapasiteli
kabiliyeti
arkadaşlar
capabilitiesi
en yüksek olan
bir de
ne vardı
scope lock
bir de
shared lock
işte oradaki
scope lock
sınıfı
onun
constructörü
zaten
doğrudan
varyadık
dolayısıyla
eğer burada
arkadaşlar
lock card
sınıfını
kullansaydım
herhangi bir şekilde
bu lock fonksiyonunu
çağırmadan
sadece ve sadece
tek yapmam gereken
lock card
sınıfının
constructörünü
hemen
kitlemek istediğim
ne kadar
mutex varsa
hepsini
argüman olarak
geçmek
e şimdi
eksik bir şey yoksa
örneği bozmamışsak
bu
slot lock
fonksiyonuna yapılan
çağrıdan sonra
tekrar çalıştırıyorum
bakın
aralık sıramıra
önemli değil
ister burada
a b
önce olsun
hangisi önce
hangisi sonra
iki tane
mutex de olsa
üç tane
fark etmiyor
evet bakın
herhangi bir şekilde
deadlock oluşmadı
buradaki garantiyi
veren
lock fonksiyonunun
kullandığı
arkadaşlar
algoritma
evet
peki
şimdi
evet
sadece lock fonksiyonunu
gösteren bir örnek de
yapmışım
aslında
bunu karıştırmadan
hemen onu da
görelim
bakın
iki tane mutex var
m1 m2
fakat
full fonksiyonu da
lock'ı çağırıyor
bar fonksiyonu da
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
buradaki lock
tekrar söylüyorum
sınıfın üye fonksiyonu
olan lock değil
arkadaşlar bir de şöyle
enteresan bir
isimlendirme problemi oluyor
bakın şimdi çok komik
incelediğiniz örneklere de
ya da okuduğunuz
üretimde okuduğunuz
kodlara da dikkat edin
bir
mutex sınıflarının
hatta buraya yazayım
isimlendirmeye
dikkat diye
dikkat
bir
mutex sınıflarının
lock
isimli
fonksiyonu
var
iki
bazı
diyelim
guard
sınıflarının
yani
ray sınıflarının
örneğin
unique lock'ın
lock
isimli
fonksiyonu
var
ama bu
guard sınıfının
lock fonksiyonu
mutex'in
değil
evet tabii
tahmin ediyorsanız
o da sarmaladığı
mutex'in lock
fonksiyonunu çağırıyor
lock isimli
fonksiyonu
var
üç
global
lock fonksiyonu
var
global
variadic
global derken
free
anlamında
global
variadic
lock fonksiyonu
var
şimdi daha da
kötüsü
birçok programcı
developer'ların
çoğu
yani
multi-thread
kodları yazan
guard
nesnelerine
lock
ismini
veriyorlar
yani
şöyle
örneğin
lock
guard
diyelim ki
mtx
bir
mutex
nesnesi
olsun
burada
işte o
rayı
ilkesiyle
mutex'i edinen
destroy olduğunda
mutex'in
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağıran
sınıf
türünden
nesnenin
ismi
lock
ama bu
aslında bir sınıf
şablonu
burada
işin içine
bir de ne giriyor
c++17 ile
dile eklenen
sitat da giriyor
çünkü
normalde
lock
card
jenerik bir sınıf
yani bu demek
bu şu demek
rayı sınıfları
herhangi bir
mutex
türünden
mutex'i alabiliyor
yani örneğin
lock
card'ın
mutex açılımı
da olabilir
ama
lock
card'ın
pimed
mutex
açılımı da
olabilir
lock
card'ın
recursive
mutex
açılımı da
olabilir
lock
card'ın
recursive
timed
mutex
açılımı da
olabilir
dolayısıyla
ortalık
lock
ismiyle
dolu olduğu için
biraz
işler
karışıyor
diyebiliriz
evet
peki
devam
arkadaşlar
bakın
çok güzel bir örnek
daha
biraz bekleteceğim
ama
çok kod var
çünkü
şimdi
baktım
sadece bu
concurrency
konusunda
200'e yakın
kod yazmışım
hani
derste
anlatmak üzere
tabi hepsi
bu kursa değil
bazıları
ilerisi
plus plus
kursunda
şimdi bu
koda bakalım
arkadaşlar
ismi
thread
unsafe
singleton
çünkü burada
thread safe
olmadığını
anlatmak için
yazılan bir örnek
şimdi
yavaş yavaş
bakalım
artık singleton'ın
ne olduğunu
herkes biliyor
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
bu
nerede
tamam
sınıfın
olması gerektiği
gibi
bu klasik
implementasyon
da olması
gerektiği
gibi
statik bir
veri elemanı
var
bu da
sınıf
türünden
bir pointer
biliyorsunuz
işte singleton'da
bir tane nesne
oluşturulabilmesi
ikinci nesnenin
oluşturulamaması
gerekiyor
bu arada bir yanlışlık
olmasın
tabi
burada yazmışım
çünkü
copy
constructor'ın
ve copy
assignment'ın
delete
edilmesi
gerekiyor
kopyalanmanın
engellenmesi
için
yoksa
eğer bunları
delete
etmesem
bir singleton
nesnesinin
copy
constructor'ını
kullanarak
ikinci bir
singleton nesnesi
oluşturabilirim
sadece bir
dediğim yere
bakın
bu yine
hatırlayın
modern c++'da
dileyeceklenen
bir özellik
inline
variable
yani
bu şekilde
yaptığımda
sınıfın dışında
ayrıca
tanımlamam
gerekmiyor
ve header on the library
haline
getirebiliyorum
ve tabi
value initialize
edildiği için
null pointer
değerinde
yani bu sınıfın
statik bir elemanı
olan pointer
null pointer
değeriyle
hayata
başlıyor
arkadaşlar
constructor'ın
sadece
çağrıldığını
göstermek için
standard
output'a
initializing
singleton
yazısını
çıkartıyor
burada yine
cout nesnesini
doğrudan
kullanmak yerine
osing stream'i
kullanmam
o standart
output'a
yazdırma
işleminde
cout nesnesini
senkronize
etmek için
onun konumuzla
doğrudan
alakası yok
şimdi
klasik
implementasyon
şöyle
arkadaşlar
tipik olarak
sınıfın
instance
get instance
get singleton
vesaire gibi
bir fonksiyonu
olacak
get singleton
olmaz da
burada sınıfın
ismi singleton
olduğu için
bu fonksiyon
mp'nin null pointer
olup olmadığına
bakacak
eğer mp
null pointer ise
singleton nesnesinin
henüz
dinamik olarak
new ifadesiyle
oluşturulmadığını
anlayacak
ve statik
veri elemanı
olan mp'ye
new ifadesiyle
oluşturulan
singleton nesnesinin
adresini
yerleştirecek
böylece
bu fonksiyon
ikinci kez
çağrıldığında
artık
ilk çağrıda
statik veri
elemanı
null pointer
olmaktan
çıkıp
oluşturulmuş
singleton nesnesinin
adresini
tuttuğu için
bu fonksiyonda
ikinci
üçüncü
dördüncü
çağrılarda
yeni bir nesne
oluşturulmayacak
ve
tabi burada
referans semantiği
de kullanılabilirdi
bu
client kodun
singleton nesnesini
kullanabilmesi için
bu
mp pointer'ının
yani sınıfın
statik veri elemanı
olan
oluşturulmuş
singleton nesnesinin
adresini tutan
pointer
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değerini
oluşturuyor
şüphesiz
bu
get instance
instance
vesaire
gibi isimlendirilen
yani oluşturulmuş
nesneye
erişimi sağlayan
fonksiyonda
ne olmak zorunda
statik üye fonksiyonu
olmak zorunda
arkadaşlar
işte tipik olarak
kullanımı şöyle
herhangi bir fonksiyon
içinde
global access
olması gerekiyor
ya singleton
kaderinde
herhangi bir kod
singleton nesnesini
kullanmak için
sınıfın
statik üye fonksiyonu
get singleton
burada isim
biraz kötü olmuş
get instance'ı
çağırıyor
ya da instance
diye tipik olarak
isimlendiriyor
fonksiyonu çağırıyor
o fonksiyonu
verdiği adresi
bir pointer
değişkende
saklıyor
sonra bu pointer değişken
vasıtasıyla
sınıfın üye fonksiyonlarını
çağırıyor
burada şüphesiz
mesela bu sınıfta
şöyle bir fonksiyon
olsaydı
singleton'ı
herkesin bilgini
varz ediyorum
o yüzden bunları
eklemedim
ne yapacaktı
mesela bu kod
full fonksiyonunu
çağırmak için
ps
ok
full
diyecekti
hatta hatta
izleyip
buna da gerek yok
eğer amaç
sadece burada
singleton nesnesinin
bu ifadede
kullanmaksa
doğrudan
member selection
operator'ı
kullanarak
full'yu
böyle de
çağırabilir
değil mi
illa bir fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değerini
bir değişkende
saklama
ihtiyacı yok
ama şimdi
böyle yazmanın
nedeni
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
full fonksiyonunun
içinde
33.
satırda
singleton nesnesinin
adresini
yazdırıyorum
biliyorsunuz
belki hatırlıyorsunuz
o stream sınıfında
bir üye fonksiyonu var
inserter
void star parametreli
void yıldız parametreli
herhangi türden bir adresi
eksadesim
sayı sisteminde
yazdırıyor
şimdi
örneği neden böyle yazdığımı
tahmin ediyorsunuz
değil mi
yanlış anlaşılmasın
şimdi bu sınıf
kötü
ya da yanlış
değil
yani bu sınıfı
kullanan
bunun
thread safe
olmadığını
bilerek kullanacak
normalde sınıfların
dokumentasyonunda
bu zaten
yazıyor
thread safe
olup olmadığı
yazıyor
burada kesinlikle
thread safe
değil
neden thread safe
son derece
basit işte
ben
bu arada
şunu da sileyim
ben burada
arkadaşlar
full fonksiyonunu
birden fazla
threadle çalıştırırsam
thread
get singleton
fonksiyonu
çağrıldığında
işte şuradaki
get singleton
fonksiyonu
çağrıldığında
biri mp'nin
değerini null pointer
olarak okurken
diğeri de mp'nin
değerini null pointer
olarak okuyabilir
değil mi
bu durumda
singleton olmayacak
sözde singleton
olacak çünkü
ikinci
dinamik ömürlü
nesne
oluşturulacak
belki üçüncü
işte burada
eğer bunun
thread safe
olması
isteniyorsa
ya az önce
gösterdiğim gibi
ideali
double checked
locking
pattern
denilen
hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi
15-20 dakika
önce gösterdiğim
bir örüntü
kullanılacak
ya da
bir çözüm
daha var
birazdan onu
göreceğiz
ama önce
bu kodu
bir çalıştıralım
thread safe
olmadığını
görelim
main fonksiyonu
içinde
bir
c thread
vektörü
oluşturulmuş
neden
c thread'i
kullandığımı
artık
açıklamıyorum
sınıfın
vektör sınıfının
iki tane
pushback
overloadu
olduğu için
biri
l value
const l value
ref
diğeri
r value
ref
parametreli
defalarca
konuştuk
putback'e
gönderdiğim
argüman
arkadaşlar
isimlendirilmemiş
bir
temporary
objekt
olduğu için
parametresi
r value
referansı
olan
fonksiyon
çağrılacak
böylece
herhangi bir şekilde
problem
olmayacak
değil mi
yani
vektöre
bu
j thread
nesnesini
eklemiş oldum
böylece
20 tane
thread
oluşturmuş
oldum
20 thread
defu'yu
koşturuyor
defu
her bir
thread tarafından
koşturulduğu
zaman
get singleton
fonksiyonu
çağrılıyor
ama
get singleton
fonksiyonunda
mb pointer'ı
arkadaşlar
ne olmadığı için
senkronize
edilmediği için
burada
artık singleton
olma garantisi
yok
değil mi
yani
data race
oluşuyor
evet
şimdi bakın
arkadaşlar
görüyor musunuz
initializing
singleton
e nasıl
olabilir
3 tane singleton
nesnesi
oluşturduğunu
görüyoruz
zaten
dikkat ederseniz
adresler de
farklı
oysa
bu
thread safe
olsaydı
100 tane
thread
oluştursam da
bir tane
singleton
nesnesinin
oluşması
garanti
altında
olacaktı
şimdi
burada
bu örneği
vermemin
geçen derslerden
birinde
konuşmuştuk
ama
önemli bir
amacı
daha var
arkadaşlar
bir de
mayor singleton
denilen
bir singleton
örüntüsü
var
aslında
kursun
başında
ben
anlatmıştım
mayor singleton'ın
neden
faydalanıyor
statik
yerel
değişkenler
statik
yerel
değişkenlerin
şöyle bir
özelliği
var
değil mi
programın
akışı
bu
statik
yerel
değişkene
sahip
fonksiyon
ilk kez
çağrıldığında
statik
yerel
değişken
hayata
geliyor
arkadaşlar
ama
ikinci
üçüncü
dördüncü
kez
çağrıldığında
siz aynı
değişkeni
kullanmış
oluyorsunuz
ve bravo
modern
c++
itibariyle
hatta ondan
biraz daha önce
c++'ın ilk zamanlarında
bu
thread safety
garantisi yoktu
ama şimdi artık
statik yerel
değişkenlerin
initialize edilmesi
thread save
yalnız
bir yanlışlık
olmasın
sadece
initialize edilmesi
onu kullandığım
her yer
tabi ki
bu da çok tipik
yanlış anlamalardan
biri
thread safety
arkadaşlar
şimdi
mayor singleton'ını
görelim
singleton'ın bir
pattern'ın ismi
programlama dilinden
bağımsız
herhangi bir
dilde
arkadaşlar
singleton
pattern'ı
implement edilebilir
ama tabi
c++'da
singleton'dan
ne beklediğimize
bağlı olarak
en az
böyle
10 farklı
singleton
implementasyonu
olabilir
yani örneğin
kalıtı mı
yapılacak mı
yapılmayacak mı
nesne için
destructor'ın
çağrılması
şart mı
yoksa
destructor
çağrılmasa da
olur mu
mesela bir örnekle
oklasik singleton'da
destructor
zaten çağrılmıyor
onu
göze alarak
öyle yapacaksınız
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakın
her şey
aynı
bu
her şey
aynı derken
bir şey
yanlış yazılmış
çünkü
şuna artık
gerek yok
değil mi
mp
öbürü koddan
kopyalaymıştırdan
kalmış
onu ben
kitaptan da
düzeltim
şimdi
bakınız
burada ise
arkadaşlar
get singleton
fonksiyonu
içinde
statik ömürlü
bir yerel
değişken var
bu fonksiyon
ilk kez
çağrıldığında
yine
statik
yerel
nesne
hayata
gelecek
fakat
statik
yerel
değişkenlerin
az önce
Alihan Bey'in
söylediği gibi
initialize edilmesi
thread safe
yani burada
herhangi bir şekilde
ne gerekmiyor
bir
senkronizasyon
gerekmiyor
ve
arkadaşlar
fonksiyon
sadece
s'yi
referans
semantiği ile
döndürüyor
dolayısıyla
kaç tane
thread
bunu
çalıştırırsa
çalıştırsın
ilk defa
bu
fonksiyonu
çalıştıran
thread de
initialization
thread safe
olduğu için
nesne
oluşturulacak
ama ondan sonra
aynı nesne
kullanılıyor
olacak
şimdi burada
full fonksiyonda
yine
böyle bir
referans
değişken
tanımlamamın
nedeni
yine
adreslerin
hep aynı
olduğunu
göstermek
yoksa
adresler
aynı olduğunu
göstermek gibi
bir kaygımı
olmasaydı
bu ifadeyi
doğrudan
bu sefer
arkadaşlar
geri dönüş
değeri
referans
olduğu için
nokta
operatörünü
hatta
gösterelim
mesela burada
sınıfın
bar isimli
bir
non-statik
üye fonksiyonu
olsaydı
referans
değişken
hiç
kullanmadan
nokta
operatörüyle
arkadaşlar
bar fonksiyonunu
bu şekilde
çağırabilirdim
anlaşıldı
değil mi
statik
local
array
olsa da
garanti
veriliyor
mu
şimdi
soru
biraz
düşünmem
lazım
tam soruyu
algılayamadım
statik
dizi
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
eğer
kastettiğimiz
şuysa
mesela
diyelim ki
burada
statik bir
yerel dizi
var
yerel dizinin
elemanları
da
evet evet
o garanti
var
yani
herhangi bir şekilde
orada problem
yok
peki
şimdi
ilk yazdığım
koda geri
döneyim
burada
sadece
singleton
nesnesinin
bir
pointer
ya da
referans
değişkeni
olmadan
da
doğrudan
get instance
burada
get singleton
isimli
fonksiyonun
çağrı ifadesinin
eğer geri dönüş değeri
pointer ise
ok operatörünün
sol operandı
bu örnekte
olduğu gibi
geri dönüş değeri
referans türü ise
nokta operatörünün
sol operandı
yapabilirdi
diğer konularda
herhangi bir farklılık
yok
yine 20 tane
track çalıştırıyorum
her şey aynı
o yüzden
açıklamıyorum
ve
arkadaşlar
bakın
sadece
bir kez
initialization
singleton
yazısı
çıktı
arkadaşlar
ama
hatta
arttıralım
şimdi
20 değil
100 yapalım
hani bir
kaza yapalar
gelir mi diye
düşünseniz
çünkü 20 tane
de
olabilir
ama bakın
sadece ve sadece
bir kere
çıktı
bu örnekte
statik
yerel nesnelerin
initialization'ın
ne olduğunu gösteriyor
arkadaşlar
thread safe
olduğunu gösteriyor
yalnız bir şey
yanlış anlayış olmasın
şimdi ben bu
singleton nesnesini
kullandığım yerde
birden fazla
thread
bu singleton nesnesini
kullanıyorsa
senkronizasyon
yapmak zorunda
mıyım
cevap
tabi ki
yani o ikisini
birbiriyle karıştırmayın
initialization'ı
thread safe
yoksa onu
kullandığım yerde
thread safe
değil
anlaşıldı
değil mi
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
gelelim
diğer
mutex sınıflarına
evet
zamanımız da azaldı
şimdi ne demiştik
aslında
bir tane
mutex sınıfı yok
hangi mutex sınıfları
vardı
bir sayalım mı
necati
say
stut mutex
stut
recursive
mutex
stut
timed
mutex
stut
recursive
timed
mutex
stut
shared
mutex
arkadaşlar
timed
shared
mutex
bunların farklı farklı
özellikleri var
şimdi
arkadaşlar
buradaki
problemlerden biri
bazı kodlarda
ister istemez
eğer farklı bir tasarım
yapmıyorsak
tasarım bizi
neye zorluyor
bu da tek mecburiyet
değil tabi
aynı mutex'i
kilitliyken
yani ismi örneğin
mtx
isimli bir mutex
var
onun
lag fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
kilitliyorum
fakat sonra
tekrar
lag fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
hiçbir tanımsız
davranış olmadan
gerçekten
ikinci kez
kilitleniyor
üçüncü kez
necati peki
bu
recursive
mutex sınıfının
böyle bir özelliği
var değil mi
evet
yani gerçek
aman aman
recursive
mutex
değilse
recursive
mutex
ya da
recursive
time
mutex
değilse
yani
sınıfın
isminin içinde
recursive
sözcüğü
geçmiyorsa
kesinlikle
kilitliyken
ikinci kez
kilitlemeye
çalışmayın
çünkü ikinci kez
kilitlemeye
çalışırsanız
zaten kilitliyken
aynı kiliti
tekrar edinmeye
çalışacak
anlaşıldı
değil mi
evet
işte
eğer
kullandığımız
mutex
recursive
mutexlerden
biriyse
en kez
kilitleyebiliyorum
ama
burada
en kez
kilitliyorum
derken
o en değerinin
ne olduğu
tamamen
derleyiciye
bağlı
arkadaşlar
bir de size
şöyle bir şey
göstermek istiyorum
biraz müsaade
ederseniz
şimdi bitmedi de
yani yarım haliyle
bakmayın
şimdi ben
özellikle
concurrency
konusunda
şöyle de
açayım
kitapta
bitmedi
yalnız söyleyeyim
şu hali
epey zayıf
ama bunu
mükemmel hale
getirmeye
çalışacağım
bakın şöyle
notlar diye
bir kısım var
zz ile başlattım da
en sonunda
görünsün
diğerleriyle
karışmasın
diye
burada
artık
sınıfları
anlatan
doğrudan
tekster
oluşturuyorum
arkadaşlar
mesela
neydi
şimdi
recursive
mutex
buraları
biraz
acele yazdım
buraları
düzelteceğim
çok daha fazla
ayrıntı koyacağım
ama sadece bir örnek
şimdi
recursive
mutex
diyelim ki
unuttuk
recursive
mutexler
stud
recursive
mutex
ve recursive
timed
mutex
sınıfları
tarafından sunulur
mesela burada
shared
mutex
yokmuş
demek ki
daha bu
metni
yazdığımda
onu da eklemem
gerekiyor
recursive
mutex
sınıfı
stud
mutex
sınıfına
benzer
ancak
yeniden
kilitlemeye
izin verir
izin verilen
kilitleme sayısı
derneğiciye
bağlıdır
oraya dikkat etmeniz
gerekiyor
yani bir derleyici
mesela 10 kez
kilitlemeye
izin verirken
diğeri 5 kez
kilitlemeye
izin verebilir
yani o
6. kez kilitlediğinizde
çalışmayacak
bir mutex
a thread'i
tarafından
ilk kez
kilitlendikten
sonra
a thread'i
mutex üzerinde
ek kilitler
edinebilir
hali hazırda
sahip olduğu kilidi
serbest bırakmadan
a thread'i
mutex üzerindeki
tüm kilitlerini
serbest bırakana
kadar
mutex
diğer thread'ler
burada
iç parçacığı
terimini kullanıyorum
bazen Türkçede
diğer thread'ler
tarafından
kullanılamaz
öz yinelemeli
işte bu
dil düzeltecek
çok hızlı yazsın
öz yinelemeli
yani rekürsif
sözcüğünün
Türkçesi olarak
öz yinelemeli
terimini
kullanıyorum
mutex
genellikle bir
mutex'i kilitleyen
kodun
aynı mutex'i kilitleyen
başka bir kodu
çağırması
gerektiğinde
kullanılır
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
iki tane
tipik senaryo var
iki senaryo da önemli
biri
zaten
bir arkadaşım
yazmıştı
evet
dedi ya
Resul Mehmetov yazmıştı
soru olarak
biri
rekürsif fonksiyonlarda
çünkü rekürsif fonksiyon
demek
kendi kendini çağıran
fonksiyon demek
rekürsif fonksiyonda
critical kod varsa
o zaman
fonksiyon
kendisini çağırdığında
kendisini çağıran
kod yine
o critical koda
girecek
ve aynı
mutex nesnesi
kullanıldığına göre
ikinci kez
üçüncü kez
kilitlenecek
takip edebildik mi
ama bir başka
senaryo daha var
o da
internal
synchronization
durumu
internal
synchronization
dan neyi
kastediyorum
şimdi bir örnek
yapmıştık ya
hani bir
container sınıf
bir container
nesnesini
sarmalıyordu da
bütün
üye fonksiyonları
senkronize ediyordu
ama bazen
şöyle bir durum oluyor
bir üye fonksiyon
bir üye fonksiyonu
çağırıyor
şimdi kafanızda
canlandırın
öyle bir örnekle
yazdım ama
sadece şimdi bir
sözün olarak
üstünden geçelim
şimdi
sınıfın
fon fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
burada
kilit sistemini
kullanıyor
mutex'i kullanıyor
takip edebiliyor muyuz
ama
bar fonksiyonu da
kilitlemeye
sahip
çünkü neden
e
client'lar
full fonksiyonunu
da kullanabilir
ama
bar fonksiyonunu
da çağırabilir
ikisi de
public interfeste
takip edebiliyor muyuz
ama
full fonksiyonu
mutex
kilitliyken
kendi üye fonksiyonu
barı çağırıyor
şimdi diyeceksiniz ki
e madem
kilit altında
çağırıyor
normalde
mesela bu
private fonksiyon
olsaydı
burada
senkronizasyonu
uygulamama
gerek kalacak
mıydı
hayır
ama problem ne
bar da
public fonksiyon
fu da
barı
client kodlar
doğrudan
çağırabilir
o ayrı bir iş
yapıyor
ama
fu'nun da
yaptığı işin
bir parçası
arkadaşlar
barı çağırmak
tabi ki
burada başka
çözümler olabilir
yanlış anlaşılmasın
yani
kodu farklı
şekilde
organize edebilirsiniz
ama burada
eğer gerçekten
burada da
aynı mütex'i
kullanıyorsanız
o zaman
fu'yu çağırdığımda
mütex'i aldı
o da
barı çağırdı
arkadaşlar
aynı mütex'i
tekrar kilitliyor
durumuna düşecek
bu durumda da
bu kolun
tanımsız davranış
olmaması için
ne olması
gerekecek
mütex'in
rekörsif
mütex olması
gerekecek
şimdi kaldığımız yeri
burada işaretleyelim
yeni örneğe geçmeyeceğim
geçersem
yarıta kalacak
şarşamba günü
devam edeceğiz
şunların hepsini
bitirmeyi umuyorum
yani bütün
mütex sınıfları
arkadaşlar
peki en defa
unlock mu etmek
gerekiyor
evet en defa
unlock etmek
gerekiyor
kesinlikle
yani kaç kere
lock ettiyseniz
alahan
o kadar
unlock
edeceksiniz
aynen öyle
evet
önce
bu mütex
sınıflarını bitireceğiz
sonra guard
sınıflarını
bitireceğiz
sonra yine
birkaç tane
deadlock
senaryolarına
bakacağız
işte bütün bu
senkronizasyon
yani mütex
artı
guard
sınıfları
bittikten sonra
bundan bir sonraki
konumuz
condition
variable
efendim
future
sınıfı
stud future
stud promise
sınıfı
işte bu
provider
arkadaşlar
bir
thread'in
bir veri
üretmesi
diğer
thread'in de
o thread'in
ürettiği veriyi
kullanması için
kullanılan
yöntemler
vesaire
bunları
görmeye
başlayacağız
evet bugünkü
dersimiz burada
sona eriyor
derse katıldığınız
için teşekkür
ediyorum
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
çarşamba günü
görüşmek üzere
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
teşekkür ederim
abone ol